[musique]
Sarfo, bonjour.
Bonjour Syerview.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Avec
plaisir. Je m'appelle Sarah Knafo, j'ai
32 ans. J'ai grandi en scène Saint-Denis
à Pavillon sous-bois, pas très loin de
Holnis sous de Bondi. Ensuite, j'ai fait
de l'économie à la Sorbonne, j'ai fait
Science P, j'ai fait l'ENAT. En sortant
de l'ENAT, je suis devenue magistrate à
la Cour des comptes. J'ai inspecté les
comptes de l'État, on pourra en parler.
Euh puis je suis devenue députée
européenne. Je siège dans la Commission
industrie, recherche, nouvelle
technologie. J'ai fait un rapport sur la
souveraineté technologique. Peut-être
qu'on en parlera aussi. Et aujourd'hui,
je suis candidate pour être la prochaine
mère de Paris. Donc énormément de
choses, énormément de sujets.
On va parler Europe, Paris, budget,
dettes, plein de trucs. Première
question. Quel
quelle est la mairie de Paris avec 10
milliards de dettes ?
Ah, c'est on rentre dans le vif tout de
suite. C'est ce que j'adore sur
Syerview. 10 milliards de dettes. Vous
avez raison de dire bourbier parce que
en principe quand on regarde Paris donc
la capitale de la France, des millions
de touristes tous les ans, les sièges
sociaux de presque toutes les
entreprises françaises, on est un pays
très centralisé, on a des impôts qui
explosent, des impôts très élevés, la
taxe foncière qui a fait x 3 depuis
2001. Donc en principe, on devrait se
dire qu'on est une ville riche, presque
qu'on roule sur l'or. Et pourtant, quand
on regarde, la ville de Paris n'a pas
bouclé de budget en équilibre depuis des
années. Les socialistes sont à la mairie
depuis 2001. On a 10 milliards de dettes
pour une ville qui devrait être la
locomotive du pays et qui se retrouve à
être un boulet financier. Alors, la
question qu'on se pose en effet, c'est
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là ?
Avant d'y répond, couper.
Ouais.
Moi, j'ai je me fais la du diable. 10
milliards de dettes, c'est des
investissements sur du long terme. C'est
remettre à plat d'eau d'électricité, la
saine, faire une zone de baignade,
rajouter des espaces verts, faire une
ville fonctionnelle.
Vous faites une transition idéale
et 10 milliards à 3 %.
Et 10 milliards. Alors, comment ? En
principe, les collectivités
territoriales ont une obligation
constitutionnelle, c'est dans la loi.
Elles doivent voter des budgets en
équilibre. Vous devez avoir chaque année
quand vous votez votre budget recette
égale dépense. Mais il y a une seule
exception, c'est l'investissement. Et
c'est là où votre question est parfaite
pour la transition. On se dit en
principe si on s'endide pour investir et
tous ceux qui nous écoutent qui ont des
entreprises ou qui investissent en tant
que particulier peuvent le comprendre,
c'est que quand on s'endide pour
investir, on peut s'enrichir parce qu'on
peut avoir un revenu associé à son
investissement à l'avenir. Alors, quel a
été l'investissement de la ville de
Paris ? Est-ce que c'est dans l'eau ?
Est-ce que c'est dans des
infrastructures pour les habitants ?
Sécurité.
Est-ce que c'est dans la sécurité
dans les caméras de vidéosurve ?
Est-ce que c'est dans les caméras de
vidéosurveillance ? La réponse est
malheureusement non. On sourit. Mais en
réalité c'est triste. L'investissement a
été en majeure partie dans le logement
social. Chaque année, la ville de Paris
a fait ce qu'on appelle des préemptions.
C'est-à-dire vous avez un bien qui est
en vente sur le marché et la mairie de
Paris va le préampter pour l'acheter
elle-même. Donc elle va faire ça en
investissement. elle va s'endetter pour
investir et ensuite là on pourrait se
dire "Bon, certes, ce sera des loyers
modérés, mais ce sera des loyers quand
même. Il y aura des revenus futurs
associés à cet investissement." Ce
serait trop beau pour être vrai. Que
s'est-il passé en réalité ? Ça fait des
années que la ville de Paris utilise un
système qui s'appelle le système des
beau amphithéotiques. C'est-à-dire
qu'elle fait des opérations d'achat sur
ses logements et ensuite elle demande à
ses bailleurs de percevoir en avance des
années de loyer. Quand je dis années, il
s'agit de décennies de loyer. 10 ans de
loyer, 20 ans de loyer, 30 ans de loyer,
40 ans de loyer selon les opérations.
Donc la ville s'endette, elle achète des
immeubles, elle les prélève sur le
marché classique. He, c'est pas de la
construction, elle les prélève sur le
marché classique. Ensuite, elle perçoit
en avance des décennies de loyer. Et
quel est le problème ? C'est que
François Hollande a permis par décret à
madame Hidalgo, ils étaient très
proches, ils se sont entendus pour ça,
il lui a permis par décret de percevoir,
je l'ai sur moi si ça vous intéresse de
percevoir son entendu. Vous avez des
sources et des preuves de ça
bien sûr publique. Et donc, ils se sont
entendus. Vous avez ce décret qui est
signé de la main du président de la
République François Hollande qui permet
à madame Hidalgo de percevoir ces
décennies de loyer en avance. et ensuite
de les injecter dans ses budgets en
permanence déficitaire mais cette fois
en recette de fonctionnement. Je vous ai
dit, il y a qu'une seule manière
d'échapper à la règle d'or budgétaire
pour une collectivité, c'est s'endetter
pour investir. Elle a pas le droit de
voter des budgets en déséquilibre de
fonctionnement, juste en investissement.
Mais quand elle perçoit ces décennies de
loyer, qui en principe sont des recettes
d'investissement et qu'elle les injecte
dans ses budgets, à quoi ça a servi ? À
combler des budgets chaque année
déficitaires. Pourquoi déficitaires ?
Parce que la mairie de Paris a dilapidé
notre argent. Notre argent à tous qui
payons des taxes foncières, qui payons
des impôts locaux, qui payons des tarifs
de stationnement exorbitant. Elle a
dilapidé notre argent dans des Gabjgis
aux quatre coins du monde, dans des
subventions clientellistes à des
associations. Et tout ce que je dis, je
vais l'étayer, j'espère dans la suite de
cette émission. J'invite déjà les gens
qui nous écoutent à aller sur
argentarisiens.fr,
un site que j'ai fait qui renvoie tout
ce que j'ai dit, tout est sourcé avec
tous les chiffres, tous les tableaux.
Donc cet argent de décennies de loyer,
elle l'a injecté dans ses budgets
déficitaires. Ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous, on va hériter de la dette, mais on
va pas hériter des revenus associés.
Donc elle a brûlé notre argent, elle a
dilapidé notre argent des décennies
d'investissement qui ont été brûlés de
manière courttermiste. Et alors
aujourd'hui, que veulent les socialistes
? Ils sont addictes à ce système de
loyer capitalisé puisqu'à ce ça leur
permet de recevoir tout de suite des
millions et des millions d'euros. Alors
qu'à l'inverse, augmenter les impôts,
les gens crient, ça fait mal, ça prend
ça prend politiquement ça, on prend un
risque quand on augmente les impôts. Ça
les a pas empêché de le faire. Hidalgo
en 2023 + 53 % de taxe foncière. Mais ça
c'est un système facile. On s'endett, on
endettte la ville, on perçoit des loyers
capitalisés tout de suite. Quand
Emmanuel Grégoire, c'est aujourd'hui le
candidat à la mairie, socialiste, donc
l'héritier d'Annie Dalgo, dit qu'il veut
aller jusqu'à 40 % de logements sociaux.
On comprend bien qu'en réalité c'est une
fuite en avant. Aujourd'hui, on est à 25
%. Dans certains arrondissements de
Paris, le 19e, on a déjà dépassé les 43
%. dans le 13e, c'est la même chose.
Quand il dit qu'il veut aller jusqu'à 40
% de logement social à Paris, on
pourrait se dire que c'est de la justice
sociale. On pourrait se dire que c'est
parce que lui, il est humaniste et qu'il
a un grand cœur. Pas du tout. C'est un
principe financier, une nécessité
financière. Ils ont construit un système
de pondzi immobilier avec notre argent
et encore une fois, on hérite des 10
milliards de dettes, on n'héritera pas
des revenus associés. Alors maintenant
la solution parce que les mots sont
forts. Quand je dis pondi immobilier, il
faut mesurer quand même ce que c'est
comme cercle vicieux et comme fuite en
avant. Je suis la seule à proposer de
renverser totalement ce système. Les
autres disent juste qu'il faut en rester
là. Quand je dis les autres, certaines
personnes à droite, vous avez monsieur
Bronazelle, madame Datti, ils disent
juste il faut s'arrêter là. Il faut pas
se contenter de s'arrêter là vu
l'ampleur du scandale. Il faut renverser
la table. Donc je propose, je finis
juste sur la mesure moratoire total et
immédiat sur le logement social. On ne
transformera pas Paris en HLM géant.
Moratoire total. Deuxièmement, vente de
10 % du parc social en priorité à leurs
occupants. C'est-à-dire qu'on va
permettre à des gens qui sont arrivés
dans le logement social de devenir
propriétaire de leur bien. C'est ça la
vraie justice sociale. 1500 le m²,
c'est de leur permettre d'accéder à la
propriété. Je réponds à votre
interrogation. Vous avez des gens qui
sont arrivés dans le logement social il
y a 10 ans, il y a 15 ans à une époque
où ils avaient des revenus modestes qui
correspondaient au critère d'attribution
des logements sociaux. Depuis, imaginez,
il y a que 10 15 ans, ils ont gravi les
échelons dans leur entreprise, ils sont
enrichis, ils ont parfois mieux gagné
leur vie et c'est normal dans une
carrière, il y a toujours une forme
d'augmentation des revenus. Sauf
qu'aujourd'hui, la loi française, faut
le savoir, interdit de sortir du
logement social quelqu'un qui ne
correspond plus au critères
d'attribution. Vous n'avez pas le droit
de le sortir du logement social. La
seule chose que vous puissiez faire,
c'est d'augmenter les loyers jusqu'à 30
%. Ça, on peut le faire. Ces gens-là,
pour beaucoup de bonne foi, ils aiment
leur appartement. Ils s'y sont
installés, ils s'y sentent chez eux, ils
ont élevé leurs enfants. Si vous leur
proposez de leur vendre cet appartement,
la mairie peut accorder des facilités.
Elle peut par exemple les exonérer des
droits de mutation à titre onéreuse
qu'on appelle les frais de notaire.
C'est 6,3 % de la valeur. La mairie peut
dire "J'exonère les primaux accédents
pour favoriser l'accès à la propriété."
Donc vous les aidez à devenir
propriétaire de leur logement. Ce que je
raconte est très réaliste, hein. Il y a
une loi qui s'appelle la loi élan et qui
permet de vendre des logements sociaux à
leurs occupants. L'année dernière en
France, on en a vendu 12000. Donc moi,
ce que je propose 10 % du parc social,
ça équivaut à en vendre 4000 par an. On
va trouver à Paris 4000 personnes qui
veulent acheter leur logement. à mes
yeux, c'est ça la vraie justice parce
que ça va créer un esprit de
responsabilité, un esprit de
copropriété. Quand vous devenez
propriétaire, il y a un plus grand
respect des parties communes. Il y a une
sorte de de responsabilité réciproque
qui s'installe entre les
copropriétaires. Donc ce que je veux
faire demain, si je suis maire de Paris,
c'est de sélectionner des immeubles, de
vendre dans cet immeuble tous les
logements à leurs occupants pour que
dans un même immeuble, il y ait pas un
un immeuble mixte avec à un étage des
propriétaires, à un autre des
locataires, mais de faire un immeuble
entier de propriétaire. Il y a beaucoup
de gens qui sont ravis de cette mesure,
qui viennent me voir en me disant
"J'adorerai acheter mon bien. J'ai peur
d'en partir. J'ai élevé mes enfants, je
me sens bien à l'intérieur. J'aimerais
acheter ce bien. C'est quelque chose qui
se fait ailleurs en France. Il faut que
ça se fasse demain à Paris." Vous avez
le système inverse, j'en finis par là.
Vous avez aujourd'hui le système inverse
avec les socialistes. Eux veulent une
ville d'affidé, de gens à qui ils ont
rendu des services. C'est ça le
socialisme. Créer du clientélisme,
arroser avec l'argent des autres.
Évidemment, ce serait trop beau qu'ils
soient vraiment généreux, ils arrosent
avec notre argent.
C'est-à-dire qu'en réalité, ils prennent
sur notre compte en banque et ils font
croire qu'ensuite ils sont généreux,
altruistes, pas du tout. Comme je vous
ai décrit ce système, il nous endettent
sur des décennies et puis ensuite il
dilapide cet argent dans des Gabj sans
nom. Et je reviendrai peut-être sur les
Gabg.
Alors première question réponse courte
4000 primo accédent ça fait rentrer
combien d'argent ?
Ah bah ça dépend de la valeur des biens,
ça dépend de la surface au mètres
carrés. Donc ça ce que ça va faire sur
10 ans en vendant 10 % du parc social,
ce qu'on a vu en moyenne c'est que ça
rapportait 8 milliards d'euros sur 10
ans. Grâce à ces 8 milliards d'euros sur
10 ans, j'arrive à diviser la dette de
Paris par de combien de temps
de nouvelles en 10 en 10 ans. Ça c'est
ce qui prend du temps. On va peut-être
venir sur des mesures qui sont rapides
où je peux vous dire le jour 1 quand
j'arrive à mon bureau de mer, je peux
les prendre. Je sais que c'est rapide,
facile, parfois c'est un trait de plume,
un arrêté municipal. Là faut pas mentir
aux gens. Faut pas faire de fausses
promesses. Je déteste la démagogie en
matière financière. Je vous ai dit que
c'était mon métier, les finances
publiques. Donc là, ça prend du temps.
Désendetter la ville de Paris, sortir de
ce système vicieux dans lequel ils nous
ont fait entrer, ça prendra 10 ans. Pour
diviser la dette de Paris par 2 à
horizon 10 ans, on va vendre 10 % du
parc social. Et par ailleurs, un plan
d'économie de 10 milliards d'euros qui
là me permet de baisser drastiquement
les impôts des parisiens. Si vous
voulez, je développe sur les 10
milliards.
On va on va revenir sur les 10
milliards. Première question. Euh vous
mettez en cause la mairie de Paris et
Annie Galg sur une gabie financière.
Moi en tant que citoyen, je me dis il y
a forcément des organismes de contrôle
qui contrôle les notes de frais, qui
contrôle les investissements.
Il y a eu des sonnets d'alarme de tirer,
pas de tirer. Est-ce que c'est contrôlé
? Pas contrôlé. Est-ce que c'est
légitime ? Pas légitime ? Alors, vous
avez eu en effet, si vous regardez sur
internet, si vous écrivez loyer
capitalisé, beau amphithéotique, mairie
de Paris, vous allez trouver des euh des
articles, vous allez trouver des
journalistes qui ont investigué mais il
y a pas eu de scandale généralisé et
comme souvent d'ailleurs on entend des
éléments, on sait qu'il y a quelque
chose qui se passe. Je vous prends un
exemple, le scandale de Paris Habitat
dans les HLM, ça a fait la une du
Parisien.
Qu'est-ce que c'est
la semaine dernière ? Le scandale de
Paris Habitat. Donc Paris Habitat, c'est
le bailleur principal de logements
sociaux à Paris. La ville de Paris en
est détentrice à 100 % de Paris Habitat.
Vous avez un communiste comme Yann
Brossa qui siège au conseil
d'administration de Paris Habitat depuis
12 ans. Donc quand vous regardez le
Parisien, c'est documenté. Ça fait la
une du journal il y a de semaines. À
l'intérieur, ce qu'on vous explique
clairement c'est qu'il y a des arnaques
à tous les étages. Des travaux qui sont
surfactur des arnaques. Il y a eu des
arnaques. C'est que
Est-ce qu'il y a des décisions de
justice ? Si c'est la question, il en
faudrait.
Est-ce qu'il y a eu des enquêtes de
diligenté ?
Il en faudrait. Mais vous en connaissez
plein des scandales en France
aujourd'hui qui font l'objet d'article
mais où quand il y a pas euh soit un
front commun politique, soit la justice
qui s'emmêle, bah on a l'impression
qu'on a tous les signaux, c'est à bas
bruit. On a les documentations, on peut
le lire, on peut voir euh ce que je
raconte typiquement c'est de l'open data
de la mairie de Paris. On peut aller sur
le site de la mairie de Paris, on va
trouver les délibérations. Donc on y
verra des sources. Mais si la classe
politique ne dit pas au bout d'un moment
on tire la sonnette d'alarme, on
comprend déjà il faudrait qu'il
travaille. Vous êtes d'accord les autres
? Il faudrait que ils s'intéresse
beaucoup plus au dossier. Là quand je
vous en parle, il y a des gens qui me
disent "Vous me l'avez appris. Pourtant
on peut trouver toutes les sources et
Pourquoi ça sort que maintenant ?
À votre avis ?
Parce que c'est avant les élections.
Bah parce que je viens de me présenter à
la mairie de Paris que j'étais pas
candidate il y a 6 ans. Je n'avais pas
encore l'âge d'être candidate,
qu'aujourd'hui je suis candidate et que
je mets le dossier sur la table. Quand
j'ai sorti tous les dossiers de l'Agence
française de développement, pourquoi
c'était pas sorti avant ? Pourtant, tout
était sur afd.fr. Pourquoi est-ce qu'on
m'a attendu pour que enfin on baisse le
budget de l'aide au développement de 2
milliards d'euros avec le directeur
général de l'Agence française de
développement qui a dit que c'était
grâce à moi, enfin lui a dit que c'était
à cause de moi avec son langage de
d'homme qui a dorilé notre argent. lui
dit c'est parce que Sarah Knafo c'est
malheureusement non c'est pas gratuit ça
coûte très cher hein vous savez mais il
lui a dit Sarah Knafo a décrédibiliser
l'aide au développement et à cause
d'elle on doit baisser les budgets.
Merci monsieur pour moi c'est une légion
d'honneur. Je fais économiser 2
milliards à mes concitoyens avant même
d'arriver au pouvoir. On peut me
remercier n'est-ce pas sur la mairie de
Paris. Je vais faire pareil en arrivant
au pouvoir. Je vais permettre aux
Parisiens d'économiser 10 milliards
d'euros encore une fois sur 10 ans. Un
plan d'économie de 10 milliards sur 10
ans qui va me permettre cette fois dès
le premier budget de diviser la taxe
foncière par de pour tous les
propriétaires parisiens, les entreprises
comme pour les ménages et de diviser par
deux les deux taxes qui pèsent sur les
locataires. Tout le monde y gagne
propriétaire comme locataire. Deux taxes
qui pèsent sur les locataires, taxes
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères et
taxes de balayage qui sont répercutés
sur les loyers. Deuxième chose pour le
pouvoir d'achat des Parisiens, quel que
soit leur niveau de revenu, baisse
drastique des tarifs de stationnement.
Je vais rétablir la gratuité pour les
deux roues. Je crois que ça vous
concerne.
Donc rétablissement de la gratuité pour
les deux roues qui participent au
désengorge sûrement pas. Sûrement pas.
Moi, je veux cette interview quand même.
Donc gratuit roues qui participent au
désengorgement de Paris.
Gratuité la première heure. La première
heure de gratuité, ça va aider tous les
commerçants de Paris. Ils me le disent,
leur vrai sujet, c'est le passage, c'est
le pouvoir d'achat de leurs clients qui
peuvent plus garer, qui doivent budgeter
des fortunes juste pour le
stationnement. Donc gratuité pour la
première heure qui aide aussi les
parents qui déposent leurs enfants à
l'école, les grands-parents qui les
déposent à des activités, autres sujets
auquels les autres candidats ne pense
pas, les artisans qui viennent dans
Paris, les menuisiers, les plombiers qui
me disent qu'ils ne veulent plus entrer
dans Paris parce que aujourd'hui l'heure
de stationnement coûte plus cher que le
tarif que le semioraire de leur branche.
Quand vous avez un tarif de
stationnement plus cher que votre
semiorer, c'est pas rentable,
bah ils l'intègrent peut-être dans leur
facture. Il soit ils l'intègrent dans
leurs factures, soit tout simplement ils
ne viennent plus. Donc de toute façon,
c'est du pouvoir d'achat en moins pour
les Parisiens et du service en moins
pour eux par des mauvaises décisions de
la mairie. Première heure de gratuité,
ensuite 5 € de l'heure, quel que soit le
véhicule, quel que soit
l'arrondissement, on arrête de sacrifier
les familles. Quand une mère de famille
a un véhicule familial parce qu'elle a
trois enfants, elle va pas les emmener
en trottinette. Elle a besoin de son
véhicule. Aujourd'hui, quand on quand on
est dans Paris en voiture,
manifestement, c'est pas parce que c'est
une partie de plaisir, on le fait parce
qu'on y est obligé. Quand vous êtes un
plombier et que vous avez besoin de
votre utilitaire, de la même manière,
vous pouvez pas prendre le métro avec
tous vos outils. Donc aujourd'hui,
prendre la voiture dans Paris pour
beaucoup, c'est une obligation. Je veux
faciliter la vie de ces gens. Je veux
rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux Parisiens
gratuité entre midi et 2 pour aider les
restaurateurs et aussi parce que les
gens qui vont au resto à Paris n'ont pas
à budgetter 36 € de stationnement avant
même d'avoir commandé le premier plat.
Ça, ce sont des sujets hyper concrets de
quotidien des gens et que je peux me
permettre de financer parce que j'ai un
plan d'économie de 10 milliards d'euros.
Ce que je veux vous dire, c'est à quel
point le pouvoir d'achat de nos
compatriotes est relié aux mauvaises
dépenses publiques des pouvoirs publics.
Si on arrive à baisser les dépenses, on
peut baisser les impôts, on peut baisser
les tarifs, notamment les tarifs de
stationnement pour rendre du pouvoir
d'achat aux gens. Ma philosophie à
l'échelle nationale comme à l'échelle
parisienne, c'est de dépenser moins pour
pouvoir taxer moins pour que les
Français, les Parisiens en particulier
puissent gagner plus, investir plus,
être libre de ce qu'il possède. La
propriété privée pour moi, c'est une
valeur fondamentale. Je finis sur ça,
sur la propriété privée.
La propriété privée, c'est une conquête
de la Révolution française. En principe,
ça devrait parler aux gens de gauche. Il
y a des gens qui sont morts pour ça. Il
y a des gens qui se sont battus pour que
le mot propriété ait un sens. Quand
aujourd'hui en France, on voit que
l'État nous prend plus de la moitié de
ce qu'on construit, plus de la moitié de
ce qu'on travaille, est-ce qu'on est des
esclaves finalement ? Si on n'est jamais
propriétaire de ce qu'on aimé pour
posséder, don jeis donné un autre mot
que esclave.
Dites
non,
c'était vulgaire.
Oui, très
OK. Dites pas. On la même ch
on s'est compris.
Ouais. Est-ce qu'on est des esclaves ?
Est-ce qu'on est les esclaves
aujourd'hui d'un système qui doit
prendre ce qu'on a trimé pour posséder
pour le dilapiter dans des gabgis sans
nom ? À l'échelle nationale, on voit une
dette qui est passée sous Macron de +
1300 milliards. Si mes souvenirs sont,
je demande à me faire facker.
+ 1300 milliards. On est à 3400
milliards et je peux prendre les paris
que si tout continue comme ça, quand on
sera pendant la présidentielle de 2027,
on sera à 4000 milliards de dettes.
C'est dû à quoi on voit un budget où on
voit l'État qui ne réduit pas son train
de vie, qui ne cible pas là où on
pourrait faire des économies. C'est quoi
? C'est une fuite en avant. C'est de la
subordnation de vote. C'est mettre la
poussière sous le tapis. Après moi le
déluge, c'est si je fais une réduction
de budget telle qu'il faudrait le faire,
ça va créer des émeutes, ça va épuiser
mon réservoir de vote. C'est du
clientélisme la dette. C'est quoi ?
Il y a beaucoup de questions dans votre
question. D'abord, est-ce que ça va
créer des émeutes ? Je dirais non. C'est
plutôt le contraire qui créera des
émeutes, c'est continuer comme on fait
aujourd'hui dans cette fuite en avant
délirante. Je vais dire pourquoi à mes
yeux le plan d'économie sera ce qu'il y
a de plus populaire. La personne qui le
mettra en œuvre, je pense vraiment sera
la personne la plus populaire de la 5e
République. Revenons au 1300 milliards.
Plus 1300 milliards de dettes, c'est
Bruno Lemer à lui tout seul. J'ai gagné
le prix de l'humour politique en disant
que s'il y avait une forme de
responsabilité dans la classe politique
et que Bruno Lemire voulait rembourser
tout ce qu'il nous a coûté, alors il
devrait faire la plonge pendant 62
millions d'années. Vous imaginez bien
qu'il le fera pas. Il y a pas de
responsabilité aujourd'hui. On a
l'impression que c'est l'argent de
personne. Et ça ça répond à votre
question. Personne ne s'en sent
responsable. On dilapite des milliards
comme sils étaient dans leur poche,
comme si c'était leur argent. Et vous
entendez Macron parfois aller devant des
responsables internationaux, dans des
sommets internationaux et dire moi je
vais mettre 4 milliards sur ça. C'est
vrai qu'il est au poc que c'est son
argent. 5 milliards sur ça, 6 milliards
sur les grands lacs, 7 milliards sur
ceci. C'est son argent. C'est l'argent
des gens.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Ouais.
Je vais défendre Emmanuel Macron.
Vous allez étonner tout le monde. Allez,
je vais je vais même défendre Bruno
Lemire. Bruno Lemer qui dit "Il a sauvé
l'industrie française." Déjà, c'est dur
à prononcer.
Ouais. Je me dis Emmanuel Macron, c'est
un bon président, il a mis de l'huile,
il a mis du de l'huile dans les rouages
pour éviter que ça grippe, pour éviter
qu'il y a des tensions pour la stabilité
du pays.
OK, vous le faites bien, le macroniste.
Fou, il en reste plus beaucoup en
France.
Ouais.
OK. Alors,
vous connaissez Skipi ? Non.
On va répondre.
Vous disiez tout à l'heure, est-ce que
c'est de la subordination de voix ?
Non. Subordination.
Manifestement, ça ne marche pas. On a le
président qui a cramé la caisse, qui a
dépensé plus que quiconque et c'est
aussi le président le plus impopulaire
de tous. Et là, on peut dire bravo et
merci à notre peuple pour sa lucidité.
On peut aussi lui dire merci parce que
ça donne la voix et ça montre à tous les
démagogues politiciens que ça ne sert à
rien de cramer la caisse parce que
personne ne vous en remerciera. Emmanuel
Macron qui a voulu dépenser des
milliards après chaque crise, qui
croyait peut-être naïvement que c'est
comme ça qu'il allait résoudre les
crises en sortant le chéquier qui nous a
parlé du quoi qu'il en coûte et cetera,
quoi qu'il vous en coûte. D'ailleurs, ce
même Emmanuel Macron qui tombe si bas
dans les sondages de popularité qu'on se
demande jusqu'où ça peut encore
descendre, est-ce qu'il n'est pas la
preuve finalement que les Français ne
sont pas à acheter ? Est-ce qu'il n'est
pas la preuve que nous ne sommes pas
achetables ? On peut sortir le chéquier
jusqu'à demain, ça rendra pas plus
populaire. Moi, j'ai une autre solution,
c'est plutôt d'arrêter de prendre dans
la poche des Français l'argent qu'on va
aller dilapider. Et là, on en vient à un
sujet majeur philosophiquement,
économiquement qui est de faire
comprendre que l'argent public n'existe
pas. L'argent public, c'est votre
argent, c'est l'argent de ceux qui nous
écoutent. L'argent public est
aujourd'hui dans votre poche. Ce que
l'État va dépenser demain, ce que la
mairie de Paris va dépenser demain,
aujourd'hui, c'est de l'argent qui est
sur votre compte en banque qu'on va vous
prendre pour le dépenser. Parfois dans
des folies, parfois ça sert à quelque
chose les dépenses publiques, une
police, une école, des hôpitaux qui
marchent, on serait ravi. Mais vu tout
ce qu'on dépense, vu la manière dont on
dilapide l'argent, vu le fait qu'on soit
aujourd'hui le peuple le plus taxé du
monde, 47 % de taux d'imposition en
France, le taux le plus élevé du monde.
C'est-à-dire pour que les gens qui nous
écoutent comprennent bien qu'à partir du
16 de chaque mois, vous ne travaillez
plus pour vous-même mais pour l'État
tous les mois.
Oui, on est content
à partir du 16 du mois. Alors, on serait
content si quand on arrivait aux
urgences, on était tout de suite pris en
charge avec politesse. Bonjour monsieur,
vous avez un problème ? On vous
accueille tout de suite dans les
commissariat dans Ouais, voilà. Au bout
de 8h. 5h30 d'attente en moyenne à Paris
dans les urgences, au cœur de la
capitale. 5h30 d'attente en moyenne.
Faut pas être pressé quand on va aux
urgences en France, hein. Dans les
commissariats, on devrait être accueilli
comme des princes. Tout devrait
fonctionner à l'école comme des princess
à l'école nos enfants, ça devrait être
Einstein avec le le niveau de dépense
qu'on a. Vous voyez ce que je veux dire
? On voit bien une décorrélation totale,
c'est combien ?
Attendez 2 secondes. Entre les moyens
qu'on met et la le niveau qu'on perçoit.
Quand je vous dis qu'aujourd'hui le
niveau de mathématiques moyen en France
pour des élèves de CM1 est plus faible
que celui de l'Allie.
C'est que l'Albanie est très forte. Vous
croyez ? Vous me croyez ? plus faible
que celui de l'Albe. On devrait être les
champions du monde. S'il y avait une
corrélation entre les budgets qu'on met
et le niveau de service public, alors on
devrait être des champions. À la ville
de Paris, pour reprendre cet exemple, on
a fait plus 12000 fonctionnaires depuis
2001. Je prends 2001 comme borne parce
que c'est le moment où Bertrand de la
Noé est arrivé au pouvoir. Donc ça fait
25 ans que la gauche dirige la ville de
Paris. Plus 12000 fonctionnaires depuis
2001. Dans le même temps, on a perdu
200000 Parisiens. 200000 Parisiens ont
quitté la ville. Donc plus vous avez de
fonctionnaires, moins vous avez de
Parisien. Je dis pas qu'il y a une
corrélation, mais à minima, voilà
l'effet qui existe. Ou alors moins vous
avez de Parisien, plus vous avez de
fonctionnaires. Je sais pas dans quel
sens vous voulez le prendre.
Manifestement, ça n'est pas corrélé au
services rendus. On met plus de moyens,
on rend pas un meilleur service. Vous
avez aujourd'hui 84 % des Parisiens qui
est que Paris est sale. Vous parlez à
tous les Parisiens, vous sentez bien
qu'on sent que la ville est plus sale
que par le passé, qu'elle est plus
dangereuse, plus insalubre, que les
services publics sont moins bien rendus.
Donc manifestement, on a mis beaucoup
plus d'argent et le service public rendu
n'est pas meilleur. Ça c'est un élément
à bien avoir en tête. Donc 1, l'argent
public n'existe pas. 2, ça n'est pas une
question de moyen. 3 et là, j'en viens à
la conclusion essentielle,
le pouvoir d'achat, ce n'est pas
l'argent que l'État vous donne, c'est
celui qu'il ne vous prend pas. On a
toute une classe politique démagogique
qui veut vous faire croire que votre
pouvoir d'achat, ce sera des
subventions, des chèqus, des barêes, des
chèqus scolaires, d'échec Noël, d'échec
énergie et quand sais-je ? Cet argent
là, c'est dans votre poche qu'on va le
prendre. On vous achète avec votre
propre argent.
C'est un coup de poinard dans le dos. On
vous dit qu'on va vous donner de
l'argent et en réalité on l'a prélevé
sur votre compte en banque. Mais ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que quand je
vous prends de l'argent dans la poche
droite pour vous le remettre dans la
poche gauche, je vous rendrai jamais la
somme équivalente. Imaginons que je vous
ai pris 100 € dans la poche droite pour
vous les rendre dans la poche gauche.
C'est combien le budget deation
nationale ? Arrêtez s'il vous plaît. Je
veux pas dire de bêtises. On m'a déjà
fait le coup une fois. Moi je dirai plus
de chiffres au hasard. Donc quand vous
avez on vous prend 100 € dans votre
poche droite, il va falloir des
fonctionnaires pour vérifier que vous
avez le droit euh de apercevoir cette
aide. Il va falloir d'autres
fonctionnaires pour vérifier que vous ne
fraudiez pas. Il va falloir d'autres
fonctionnaires pour vérifier la paperace
que vous avez remplie et cetera et
cetera.
Donc à la fin, quand je vous ai pris 100
€
dans la poche gauche, il va vous rester
que 50. Je peux pas vous rendre manière
équivalente ce que je vous ai pris. Donc
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le la
meilleure manière de respecter votre
pouvoir d'achat c'est de pas vous
prendre du tout cet argent. Et c'est
pour ça que je dis c'est qui va
contrôler les gens. Alors
là on parle pas de qui va contrôler les
gens. On parle de ne pas inventer de
dispositifs à contrôler. Si je crée un
dispositif, ma prime rénove, aide à la
rénovation, aide à l'achat et cetera,
vous comprenez bien que je vais vous
demander. Donc je vais vous prendre 100
€ d'impôt. Je vais vous dire mais je
vous les rendrai en prime rénov. OK ? En
attendant, vous allez devoir me remplir
50 pages de paperace pour vérifier que
vous êtes élig. Vous allez devoir payer
avec vos 100 € les fonctionnaires qui
vont relire les papiers pour voir si
vous êtes vraiment éligible, les autres
fonctionnaires qui vont vérifier si vous
n'avez pas finalement fraudé et à la
fin, je vous rendrai 50 € en vous disant
merci monsieur pour vos 100 €. Est-ce
que vous n'auriez pas préféré rénover
votre bien ou vos objets avec les 100 €
que je vous aurais laissé dans votre
poche ? C'est toute une philosophie à
changer.
Je pense que les Français peuvent nous
suivre. Le peuple français est mû pour
ça. La classe politique n'est pas mûe.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'elle a le sentiment
de servir à quelque chose quand elle
vous dit qu'elle a inventé le
dispositif. Elle en
inventé. Voilà ce que j'ai créé. Je vais
aider à la rénovation des biens. Donc je
vais inventer ce dispositif. Il faut
mettre un terme à tout ça. Toutes ces
idées socialisantes, il faut y mettre en
terme. Le pouvoir d'achat, ce n'est pas
l'argent que l'État vous donne, c'est
celui qu'il ne vous prend pas.
Je vous second
euh euh vous me résole le coup du faux
contact de caméra là. Euh est-ce que
j'ai le bug technique ?
Ouais. Alé du direct.
Alé du direct. Exactement.
Ça me permet de vous couper euh tous ces
fonctionnaires qui ont été engagés qui
font un boulot phénoménal dans des
conditions des fois la plupart du temps
craignus. Les commissariats seront on va
dire dans un état insalubre.
Ils doivent parfois payer leur
équipement.
Les contrôleurs des impôts qui se font
cracher dessus à longueur de journée,
qui se font insulter, qui comprennent
pas alors qu'ils essayent de faire
rentrer de l'argent pour faire
fonctionner l'État. Vous allez leur dire
quoi à ces gens-là ? Vous êtes trop,
vous faites pas bienir votre boulot,
vous êtes pas assez efficace ? Comment
ça se passe ?
Alors, je vais vous apprendre un scoop.
Même les fonctionnaires trouvent qu'il y
a trop de fonctionnaires.
C'est quoi votre source ?
Sondage, ifop 54 % des fonctionnaires
estiment qu'il y a trop de
fonctionnaires. Intéressant. Je vous ai
dit que j'étais au fonctionnaire.
J'étais à la cour des comptes. Je
connais pas un haut fonctionnair.
Combien ça gagne un haut fonctionnaire ?
Bah ça dépend, ça dépend des postes. À
la Cour des comptes quand on entre un
peu plus de 3000 €.
Net, brut,
net, quand on est euh donc sorti euh de
l'ENAT et euh c'est ce qu'on appelle la
botte euh dans l'administration. Donc ça
doit être parmi les salaires les plus
élevés. C'est aux alentours de 3000.
Bien français, c'est combien
pour vous donner un exemple pour vous
donner un exemple vous avez quand vous
faites mettons science po une école
comme science po des gens qui ont votre
âge qui sortent dans la banque
d'affaires qui touchent tout de suite
cin fois plus que ce que touche un haut
fonctionnaire aujourd'hui. Donc moi,
j'accuse pas les haut fonctionnaires.
C'est très important la question que
vous avez posé. J'accuse pas les haut
fonctionnaires. Quand je vous dis la
même les fonctionnaires trouvent qu'il y
a trop de fonctionnaires, c'est que
c'est un un un un système global qui est
mise en cause y compris par les
fonctionnaires et pas d'un air voilà les
tirants et cetera. C'est le système le
problème, pas les individus. Je reprends
sur la mairie de Paris. Sur la mairie de
Paris, vous avez aujourd'hui 55000
agents. C'est indéfendable. 55000 agent.
Vous avez vous avez 400 personnes à la
communication de la ville. C'est
indéfendable. Je vous ai dit qu'on avait
fait
Paris, plus belle ville du monde. Il
faut pouvoir communiquer au vanouat.
Ah oui, [rires] avec 400 personnes.
Généralement, ce qu'on dit dans la com,
c'est que plus votre bilan est
désastreux, plus vous avez besoin de
monde pour le vendre. C'est plutôt ça.
Ouais. Donc 400 personnes à la com,
indéfendable, 55000 fonctionnaires. Je
vous ai dit qu'on en avait 12000 de
moins il y a 25 ans et que pourtant tout
le monde sent bien que ça tournait
mieux, que les services publics étaient
mieux rendus. Donc indéfendable. Comment
on fait si on veut baisser la masse
salariale ? Et là je vous réponds sur on
acccuse pas les gens, c'est pas de leur
faute. C'est la la masse salarienne. Moi
la question que je me pose c'est
pourquoi il y a pas eu des alertes quand
vous me dites 400 personnes à la com.
Je vais vous répondre la même chose. On
pourrait se dire ça sur à peu près tous
les sujets français. Pourquoi il y a pas
eu des alertes en terme de diplomatie,
en terme de sécurité ? Pourquoi il y a
pas eu des alertes sur tous les sujets
qu'on connaît sur le niveau scolaire ?
Il y a eu des alertes ? Est-ce que les
gens qui ont alerté ont été écoutés pour
l'instant ? Non. Est-ce qu'il faut se
battre quand même pour que ça marche ?
Bon, votre problème technique, ça va
aller ? Non,
ça va aller. Je vais lui demander de
rajouter une batterie s'il la trouve
dans le petit tiroir là. Mais c'est bon,
ça tient.
OK, ça tourne. Donc bien sûr qu'il y a
eu des alertes. Est-ce que les gens qui
alertent sont écoutés ? Bah ça dépend, à
un moment, ils seront écoutés. Oui, je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de l'Agence
française de développement. Tout était
public. Pourquoi ça n'a pas marché avant
que j'en fasse un scandale ? Bah, il
faut que quelqu'un le fasse. Alors, je
m'y colle. Voilà, moi je le fais. J'ai
l'énergie pour le faire, je travaille
pour le faire, j'ai des équipes qui
travaillent, je sais pas tout hein, je
suis pas chat GPT et j'ai pas la science
infuse. Mais on travaille au quotidien
pour essayer de trouver ces scandales,
pour respecter aussi le travail des
Français qui contribuent et qui payent
des choses que parfois ils ne savent
même pas qu'il financent.
Il y a combien d'habitants au Paris ?
Et 2 millions. Et donc mon objectif
c'est précisément de respecter, je vous
disais tout à l'heure attaché à la
propriété privée. Votre argent, vous en
êtes le propriétaire. Si l'État vous le
prend en principe, il doit vous rendre
un service en face. Il doit faire
quelque chose pour que vous vous sentiez
qu'on vous a dépossédé de votre bien
pour quelque chose, pas pour rien, pas
pour aller le dilapider comme dans les
gabis que j'ai cité de l'Agence
française de développement. Et vous
verrez tout à l'heure quand je vais vous
lire parce que je vous ai ramené les
sources, je sais que vous aimez les
sources, quand je vais vous lire ce que
dépense la mairie de Paris, vous allez
comprendre aussi comment est-ce que les
contribuables parisiens sont spoliers de
leur argent. Si vous voulez, je peux je
peux le faire dans très peu de temps.
Dans une seconde.
Ouais. Les fonctionnaires, n'oublions
pas, je dois répondre sur comment on
baisse le nombre de fonctionnaires. Je
peux le faire ?
On attend qu'il sorte la retraite.
Bravo. Pas seulement, mais bravo. Donc
55000 fonctionnaires à la ville de
Paris. Je dis qu'il faut diviser le
nombre de fonctionnaires, le nombre
d'agents de la ville de Paris par deux.
encore une fois à horizon 10 ans.
Évidemment, je vais pas arriver le
premier jour avec un plan de
licenciement de 20000 personnes. Je vous
ai dit, je n'accuse pas les personnes,
j'accuse un système. Ce ne sont pas les
individus qui sont fautifs si la mairie
de Paris a fait n'importe quoi. C'est le
système qu'il faut renverser, pas les
gens qu'il faut attaquer. Donc eux, il
s'agit évidemment pas de les mettre au
chômage, d'avoir une forme de brutalité.
C'est pas du tout mon genre et c'est pas
ce qu'il faut faire à mon avis. Ce qu'on
m'a appris, la première chose à regarder
quand on veut baisser la masse salariale
d'une administration, c'est de regarder
le turnover naturel de cette
administration. Combien de personnes
partent naturellement chaque année ? À
la ville de Paris, c'est 3500 personnes
qui partent en moyenne chaque année.
Parfois, selon les années, c'est plus,
parfois, c'est moins. En moyenne, 3500
départ chaque année. Vous avez 1800
personnes qui partent à la retraite tous
les ans. Et ensuite, vous avez des fins
de contrat, des fins de CDD ou alors des
gens qui quittent la ville parce que on
n pas le même employeur toute sa vie.
Donc, ils vont ailleurs dans
l'administration, ils vont dans des
majorité, je ne les remplace pas. Vous
voyez déjà qu'à horizon 10 ans, ça fait
35000 postes. L'écrasante majorité, je
ne les remplace pas à part dans deux
secteurs que je juge prioritaire, la
police municipale et la petite enfance.
Là, je vais le dire, il manque des gens.
C'est la seule fois que je le dirai dans
cette interview. On manque de policiers
municipaux à Paris et on manque de
professionnels de la petite enfance. Si
vous voulez, je développe
principal.
Je vous coupe une seconde.
J'ai l'impression que euh le il y a un
faux contact dans la caméra. Vas-y,
mets-moi la batterie. Regarde si la
batterie est chargée pour pas faire
semblant que la batterie n'est pas
chargée. La batterie est chargée. La
batterie n'est pas chargée.
Bon, on voulaz pas une petite pause
comme ça vous arrangez ça.
Non non non, ça va s'arranger. On va
rester dans dans le move. Question le
nord de Paris
à côté de du du périphérique port de
clignon cour.
Ouais.
La délinquence, la drogue, les
agressions. Qu'est-ce que vous faites
avec ça ? Les camps de de gens qui
vivent dans des conditions sous les
ponts du péché euh et la colline du
craque qui a été déménagée ailleurs.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec tout ça ?
OK. Est-ce que vous avez vu Paris
pendant les Jeux Olympiques ? Ouais, on
a vu une chose incroyable pendant les
Jeux Olympiques, c'est qu'on pouvait
être en sécurité à Paris. Alors, quels
sont les enseignements qu'on peut tirer
des Jeux Olympiques puisqu'on a vu que
c'était possible de sécuriser la
capitale ? Premier élément, une présence
policière massive renforcée au sein de
la capitale. Ce que je veux faire,
conclusion, doubler les effectifs de la
ville de Paris, les porter à 8000. Il
faut les armer. Madame Hidalgo a refusé
d'armer la police municipale. Quand vous
regardez 80 % des polices municipales de
France, elles sont armées. Même dans des
villes de gauche comme Bordeaux, la
mairie a armé la police mais pas à
Paris. Et quand on se demande "Mais
pourquoi ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont
pas armés ?" C'est une question qu'on a
posé à Emmanuel Grégoire, le candidat PS
actuel. On lui a demandé la semaine
dernière sur un plateau "Pourquoi vous
refusez d'armer les policiers municipaux
?" Et il répond parce que leur métier ce
n'est pas de lutter contre la
délinquence.
leur métier, c'est de contrôler
l'incivilité.
Et donc là, on comprend d'ailleurs quand
on regarde les stats de l'activité
policière à Paris, on comprend que c'est
exactement sa philosophie, c'est que
pour lui, les policiers municipaux,
c'est des pervanches qui servent à aller
dresser des contraventions, contrôler
les centimètres sur les terrasses, aller
verbaliser des vieilles dames qui
promènent leurs chiens dans des parcs où
elles devraient pas et cetera. Donc pour
lui, le métier de la police municipale,
c'est le respect, euh le contrôle des
incivilités. Pour moi, le métier de la
police, c'est de protéger nos
concitoyens. Quand on s'engage dans la
police, on s'engage pour ça. Donc non
seulement c'est irresponsable de la part
de la mairie de Paris de ne pas armer la
police municipale. Irresponsable parce
que lorsque vous êtes un policier, qu'il
y a écrit police sur votre dos, le voyon
en face, il fait pas la distinction
municipale nationale. Vous êtes une
cible parce que c'est écrit police sur
votre dos. Aujourd'hui, on a à Paris des
policiers municipaux qui parfois sont
moins bien armés que les voyou qui sont
en face d'eux.
Comment comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent
être respectés ? Évidemment qu'ils
peuvent pas faire leur métier.
Deuxièmement, ça vous crée un problème
d'attractivité dans la police parce que
quand vous êtes une police municipale
sans armes, les autres policiers savent
que s'ils viennent dans cette police,
ils pourront plus aller au stand de tir,
ils vont perdre leur agrément. Donc
c'est pas attractif. Ils se disent que
finalement sur le marché du travail de
la police, ça va les déprécier
d'intégrer la police municipale
parisienne. Demain, vous armez la police
municipale. Ça va attirer d'excellents
profils qui vont venir avec comme
objectif de protéger leurs concitoyens.
Comment on fait pour sélectionner les
policiers municipaux ?
Bah des des recrutements. Vous faites
des recrutements avec la police
municipale. Je vous donne un exemple. la
ville de Cann David Lisnard quand il a
dit "Je vais armer la police municipale,
je vais porter les effectifs à des
effectifs plus importants", ça a attiré
de très bons profils d'anciens gendarmes
qui se sont dit "Bah là, il y a une
ambition sécuritaire pour la ville, donc
ça donne envie de venir." On peut
attirer de bons profils dès lors que la
nouvelle mairie dit "Avec moi, votre
métier ce sera pas d'aller, comme disait
Pompidou, emmerder les honnêtes gens,
mais de lutter contre la délinquence."
Et là, je réponds à votre sujet. On a
aujourd'hui dans Paris ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de zone de non droit. des
commissaires de police qui parlent en
ces termes. On a des zones où le droit
français n'est plus respecté. On a des
zones en plein Paris dans le 18e où la
mafia afghan opère. On prend Max
d'ormois. Bon bah là, il est clair qu'on
a laissé des mafias opérer avec tout un
continuum de trafic, de violence qui va
de la vente à la sovette de cigarettes
jusqu'à des réseaux de prostitution et
parfois pire et même des choses que
peut-être je ne sais pas ou qui
peut-être sont moins documentées
publiquement avec des enquêtes en cours
mais on a de véritables mafias qui
opèrent en plein Paris. Je reviens à ce
qu'on a appris pendant les JO. Je disais
plus de présence policière, assurer la
sécurité. Désolé, c'est le bé àabas,
mais on a appris quelque chose, c'est
que plus de policiers sur la voie
publique, ça voulait dire moins de
délinquants sur la voie publique.
Plus vous avez de présence policière,
plus il y a de rondes, plus il y a de
patrouille, plus vous pouvez faire des
interpellations et plus vous découragez
les délinquents. Si à partir de demain
la nouvelle maire, je suis à mon bureau
de maire et je donne ordre à la police
municipale de faire un plan
d'interpellation massif dans toutes les
zones où l'insécurité règne aujourd'hui
à Paris.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. On
discutait avec quelques policiers, il
nous disaient "Nous, on les attrape, on
les attrape et puis dans l'heure ils
sont relâchés."
J'allais vous le dire. S'il faut demain
interpeller 10 fois le même vendeur à la
sovette au champ de Mars, l'emmener au
commissariat, saisir sa marchandise 10
fois, je peux vous assurer que vous
allez le décourager parce qu'il faut un
calcul économique eux aussi. Vous êtes
vendeur à la Soviette au champ de Mars.
Mets ton nom dans sa tête. Si il se dit
cette année, je me suis fait arrêter
trois fois, on m'a saisi trois fois mais
si je fais le calcul, je suis largement
rentable.
Ce même cette ce même vendeur à la
sovette, si vous l'arrêtez quatre fois
par jour, 10 fois par jour, que 10 fois
par jour vous l'emmenez au commissariat,
vous le menoter, vous lui faites perdre
2 heures sur sa vente illégale, vous
saisissez sa marchandise, vous lui
faites perdre son sa rentabilité de la
journée. À votre avis, ça va mettre
combien de temps pour qu'il se décourage
? Et ça, vous recommencez
continuellement. Si on porte les
effectifs à 8000 comme je le souhaite,
ce genre de plan d'interpellation est
possible et vous le faites dans tous les
quartiers inlassablement. Vous l'emmenez
et peu importe d'ailleurs parce que là
on parle bien du métier de la mairie.
Évidemment que la mairie ne peut pas
mettre les gens en prison, que la mairie
ne peut pas construire des places de
prison, que la mairie n'a pas la main
sur la politique judiciaire laxiste de
l'État. Mais tout ce que peut faire une
mairie, je le ferai. Verbaliser, la
mairie peut le faire. Vous avez
d'ailleurs une loi qui arrive au
printemps solvable,
bah vous les emmenez encore une fois.
S'ils sont insolvables. On parle de
quelqu'un qui va étendre son drap,
vendre euh on parlait de cigarettes euh
de contrebande, on peut aussi parler de
souvenirs de touristes et cetera qui
alimentent parfois des trafics, parfois
pas. Mettons même qu'on a même pas
besoin de remonter jusque- là parce que
c'est le métier de la PJ et c'est pas le
métier d'une mairie. On peut les
décourager, on peut leur faire
comprendre qu'à Paris cette activité ne
sera plus rentable. Ça ça les décourage
et c'est ce qu'a montré l'épisode des
Jeux Olympiques, c'est qu'en effet plus
de présence policière décourager les
trafic. La mairie aujourd'hui, la
municipalité, la police municipale est
compétente pour aller verbaliser des
infractions sur la voie publique,
compétente pour interpeller. Demain,
vous avez une loi qui arrive ce
printemps, donc dans un ou de mois. Une
loi qui à mon avis est très consensuelle
parce qu'il y a une grande tendance pour
les polices nationales de s'appuyer de
plus en plus sur les polices
municipales. Elles sont elles-mêmes
dépassées par les sorts de la
délinquence en France. Donc on a de plus
en plus besoin d'une police municipale.
Ce qui fait qu'en tant que maire,
j'auraiis beaucoup de prérogatives, de
nombreuses compétences. On peut
interpeller et verbaliser pour tout ce
qui est déjà dans la loi. Je vous donne
quelques exemples de délit pour
comprendre jusqu'où peut aller l'étendu.
État d'ébriété sur la voie publique,
consommation de drogue sur la voie
publique, trafic de stupéfiants,
occupation illégale du domaine public,
vente illégale, on parlait des vendeurs
à la Soviette, mais demain vous avez par
exemple à la Gere Nord des gens qui
s'installent et qui ne bougent plus.
Occupation illégale du domaine public,
qui consomment de la drogue devant des
bâtiments aux portes de Paris. C'est la
honte aussi pour Paris. Paris, c'est
quand même la vitrine de la France.
Quand vous sortez à la gare du Nord, à
la gare de l'Est, quand vous voyez
l'état des gares parisiennes, c'est la
porte d'entrée sur la ville. C'est
normal que la mairie se dise à partir de
maintenant ordre sera donné d'assurer la
sécurité de tous les voyageurs aux
abords de ces gares.
Tout tout je vais dire tous ces gens
avec une situation personnelle difficile
obligée de vendre à la sauvette ou de
zoner à côté des gardes pour faire la
manche qui ont du mal à se loger. On en
fait quoi ? Une fois que vous allez les
mettre 10 fois dans un commissariat, ça
va pas changer. Ils sont insolvables.
Une fois que vous allez faire quoi ? Les
les mettre en banlieu proche, en banlieu
un peu plus lointaine ? La première
chose à comprendre, c'est que ça n'est
pas humaniste de les laisser comme c'est
aujourd'hui. Il faut pas euh tomber dans
le récit de la gauche qui voudrait que
c'est inhumain de lutter et contre les
trafics et surtout surtout contre cet
appel d'air. Quand la ville de Paris
envoie le message qu'elle est laxiste
sur ces questions, c'est qu'on continue
l'appel d'air. Je vous donne un exemple.
On parlait tout à l'heure des camps de
migrant tragédie humaine
dormir dans des tentes quchoya c'est
tout sauf la promesse qui leur avait été
faite en venant en France la première
fois que j'étais venue je vous avais
raconté que j'avais fait un stage à
l'ambassade de France en Libye qui comme
elle avait été bombardée à Tripol avait
été relocalisée à Tunis. J'avais vécu à
Tunis
et là-bas j'ai vu de près, puisque c'est
un pays de transit les méthodes des
passeurs.
Les marchés aux esclaves. Vous avez vu
aussi ? J'ai pas pu rentrer en Libye, il
y avait un marché aux esclaves. C'était
pile la même période. C'était au
lendemain du reportage de CNN terrible.
Donc de voir qu'on est revenu au
Moyen-Âge, à une époque euh bah où on
pouvait traiter les hommes comme des
esclaves du fait de ce laxisme
migratoire en Europe. C'est pour ça
qu'on en est revenu à là parce qu'on des
ce sont des gens à qui on fait croire
qu'ils vont trouver un Eldorado en
France. Et là, je reviens au passeur.
Ils leur font miroiter des fausses
promesses et nous on collabore à ce
récit quand on leur fait croire qu'on
arrivera à les accueillir dignement.
Alors que regardez les conditions
d'accueil aujourd'hui, c'est la honte.
C'est ça le pays des droits de l'homme.
Je sais plus qui avait dit la France
n'est pas le pays des droits de l'homme,
mais le pays de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme. Intéressant. On fait
croire à des gens, la gauche fait croire
à des pauvres gens qui veulent trouver
un avenir meilleur qu'ils trouveront cet
avenir meilleur en France, que la France
sera pour eux un Eldorado. Et pourquoi
les passeurs y ont intérêt ? Mais parce
que la traversée de la Méditerranée, ça
coûte selon les années 3000 €. Et avant
la traversée de la Méditerranée, il y a
la traversée du Sahara, encore plus
criminel. Mais là, bien sûr, la gauche
s'en soucie pas parce que c'est pas à
nos portes, mais vous avez des passeurs
qui laissent mourir des migrants à qui
ils ont juste extorqué les quelques
milliers d'euros que coûtaient la
traversée et puis après ils s'en souci
plus du tout. Donc pour les passeurs, il
y a un intérêt à faire croire que la
France sera un Eldorado. Sans ça, plus
personne ne voudra partir. Ils se
diront, il vaut mieux soit rester dans
notre pays d'origine, soit aller dans un
pays limitrophe dans la région où on
pourra travailler. Et ça se fait déjà.
Vous avez déjà des flux migratoires très
importants au sein même de l'Afrique
sub-saharienne et avec le l'Afrique du
Nord, même si les pays du Maghreb
essayent de freiner un peu le le les
flux migratoires, vous avez déjà des
flux importants. Il faut que des
passeurs aillent leur faire croire qu'en
France ce sera beaucoup mieux, qu'en
France ils seront logés, qu'on mettra
toujours à disposition en
réquisitionnant par exemple des gymnases
ou qu'ils auront toujours un toit,
qu'ils pourront trouver de l'argent pour
leur famille. Donc vous avez tout un
trafic de misère humaine qui se crée.
Est-ce que la France doit continuer de
collaborer à ce récit ou est-ce que
plutôt notre devoir et le plus grand
devoir d'humanisme ce serait pas de dire
on ne peut plus ?
Ceux qui sont déjà là, on en fait quoi ?
Il y a ceux qui sont déjà là. Mais
est-ce que c'est une raison pour
continuer d'accueillir 500000 personnes
chaque année ? Si vous vous arrivez chez
vous et que vous voyez qu'il y a une
fuite, est-ce que votre premier réflexe
ça va être de vider la mer avec une
cuillère, donc de s'occuper de ce qui
est déjà là ou de vous dire "Mince, d'où
vient la fuite ? Est-ce que votre
premier réflexe ça va pas être d'aller
fermer le robinet ? Si. On voit bien que
c'est ce qu'il y a de plus rationnel.
Avant de se dire on peut rien faire
parce qu'il y en a qui sont déjà là,
demandons-nous déjà quelle est la cause.
Traitons la cause avant de parler de la
misère dont on hérite aujourd'hui parce
qu'on a été laxiste pendant des années.
La première chose, traiter la cause. On
accueille aujourd'hui 500000 personnes
légalement chaque année. C'est-à-dire
qu'à l'échelle d'un quinquena, Emmanuel
Macron a accueilli l'équivalent de la
ville de Paris. Je vous disais tout à
l'heure donc accueillir autant est-ce
que c'est raisonnable ? Est-ce que c'est
humaniste ? Est-ce que c'est ça la
vision de la gauche ? Est-ce que
finalement quand il voi l'effet de leur
politique, quand il voi aujourd'hui ses
tantes, ses camp de migrants, quand il
voit les gymnases réquisitionnés,
jusqu'à quand on pourra réquisitionner
tous les gymnases de Paris qu'on
arrivera pas à loger tout ce qu'on
prétend accueillir ? On les accueille
mal, on ne sait pas les accueillir. La
politique humaniste, c'est d'arrêter cet
appel d'air. C'est ce que je propose de
faire.
Il y a combien de logements inoccupés à
Paris ? Encore une fois, je veux pas
donner de chiffres au doigt mouillé.
Est-ce que vous le savez ?
Il y en a beaucoup. Non,
il y en a beaucoup. Je peux je peux vous
l'expliquer. Je peux expliquer la cause.
On va les remettre sur le marché locatif
et je vais dire comment.
En 2019, vous avez eu l'encadrement des
loyers à Paris. Depuis l'encadrement des
loyers, on a perdu 50000 logements sur
le marché locatif. Pourquoi ? Vous avez
dit donc à des propriétaires qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas louer leur logement à au
loyer du marché, au loyer qu'ils
entendaient. Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont voulu
faire ? Ils ont tenté de contourner le
système une première fois en mettant
leur bien sur Airbnb pour retrouver de
la rentabilité. La mairie de Paris a
compris quel était le problème et la
catastrophe que pouvait causer Airbnb
dans certains quartiers et pour la
ville. Donc elle a capé le nombre de
nuités à 90 nuités maximum sur Airbnb.
Les propriétaires se sont dit bon on
peut plus les mettre sur Airbnb
262000 logements selon le dernier
recensement INC source 3 mai 2024.
Merci. Donc la mairie de Paris a compris
la catastrophe Airbnb à la cap à 90
unités maximum. Les propriétaires se
sont dit on peut pas louer au prix du
marché, on peut plus les mettre sur
Airbnb. On va essayer de trouver un
autre contournement. Puisque le
locataire est devenu vulnérable sur le
marché locatif. Vu qu'on manque de
logement sur le marché, on en a perdu
50000. Je vous disais depuis 2019, à
chaque fois qu'un propriétaire met un
bien, une annonce à louer, vous avez
tout de suite 500 appels qui arrive et
toutes les agences immobilières vous
disent "C'est fou, j'ai tellement peu de
biens allouer en ce moment que dès qu'on
met une annonce, on a tout de suite des
appels." Les locataires sont
vulnérables, ils doivent parfois
accepter certaines conditions. Donc,
vous avez des propriétaires qui
demandent au locataire, "Déclarez-vous
en résidence secondaire, comme ça, on
pourra contourner l'encadrement des
loyers et mettre des loyers plus chers."
La mairie de Paris l'a compris, elle a
créé une brigade des locataires. Donc
vous avez 30 personnes à la ville de
Paris chargé d'aller vérifier que les
locataires se soient pas fait arnaquer.
Donc on va engorger les tribunaux, on va
créer du contentieux. Tout ça au lieu de
comprendre qu'on était en train en
réalité de traiter les symptômes d'une
cause qui remontait plus loin,
l'encadrement des loyers. Certains
propriétaires se sont dit "On peut plus
les louer sur Airbnb, on peut plus
détourner avec les résidences
secondaires. Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
On va les laisser vacant parce qu'on
narrive pas à être rentable parce que
sinon on pura trop d'impôts sur les
loyers. On va les laisser vacant. Bam !
L'État impose une taxe sur les logements
vacants et on passe notre temps, comme
je viens de vous le décrire à courir
après les conséquences néfastes d'une
mesure elle-même néfaste au lieu de
comprendre que le problème, la racine du
problème, c'était l'encadrement des
loyers. Moi, je regarde beaucoup ce qui
se fait ailleurs dans le monde, les
politiques publiques un peu ailleurs. On
observe
on observe que l'une des mesures de
politique publique qui a la durée de vie
la plus faible, c'est l'encadrement des
loyers. À chaque fois qu'on la met en
œuvre quelque part, on se rend compte au
bout de quelques temps qu'en réalité ça
ne crée que la pénurie. On perdait bien
sur le marché locatif et et là miracle
de l'économie et pourtant les prix des
loyers continuent d'augmenter et vous
avez à Paris alors même que les prix des
loyers ont été encadrés on a continué la
hausse de la hausse des loyers à Paris.
La mairie de Paris parle même de
modération de la hausse des loyers. En
français normal ça veut dire hausse des
prix des loyers. Donc ça continue
d'augmenter malgré l'encadrement. En
France, on avait compris depuis 1948 que
l'encadrement des loyers était une
catastrophe et on voulait
progressivement en sortir. On en est
sorti progressivement avec plusieurs
lois de libération des loyers. Même
François Mitteron qui avait gagné avec
le programme commun de la gauche avec
les communistes n'était pas revenu sur
l'encadrement des loyers. Mêmean n'avait
pas réencadré les prix des loyers. Et il
a fallu attendre Emmanuel Macron et
Édouard Philippe pour pour permettre en
2019 aux communes qui le souhaitaent
d'encadrer les prix de leur loyer.
Résultat, vous n'avez que les villes de
gauche qui ont encadré les prix des
loyers et dans toutes ces villes, on
observe que les loyers ont continué
d'augmenter. Je vous donne un dernier
exemple pour vous montrer à quel point
cette politique est néfaste, communiste,
vraiment communiste et à quel point elle
ne produit que la pénurie. Vous avez aux
États-Unis en 2022 dans le Minnesota une
crise du logement et vous avez deux
communes qui sont voisines. Elles sont
séparé par un fleuve, c'est Saint-Paul
et Minéapolis. Ces deux communes vont
réagir totalement différemment à la
crise de la hausse des loyers qu'elles
connaissent. La commune de Saint-Paul va
décider d'encadrer ses loyers comme on a
fait à Paris. Donc on est en 2022. Elle
encadre ses loyers. À l'inverse, la
ville de Minéapolis va prendre un chemin
totalement opposé. Elle va se dire
puisque les loyers augmentent, on va
faire un choc d'offre. On va libéraliser
les constructions, on va libéraliser
l'offre, on va permettre de mettre plus
de logements sur le marché et comme ça
on résoudra la crise. Donc les deux
communes font l'opposé, elles sont
voisines, elles connaissent la même
crise. Bah, je vous le donne en 1000.
Les loyers ont continué d'augmenter de
manière très forte à Saint-Paul. À
l'inverse, à Minéapolis, la hausse a été
enrayée. À Minéapolis, vous aviez
énormément de logements sur le marché.
Alors qu'un Saint-Paul, vous aviez eu
une pénurie immédiate. Les habitants de
Saint-Paul ont décidé d'aller vivre à
Minéapolis parce que c'était plus simple
de s'y loger. Résultat, vacances
commerciale, désertification de la
ville, perte des enfants dans les
écoles. Bref, on a tué la vitalité de la
ville. C'est exactement ce qui se passe
à Paris. On perd 14000 Parisiens tous
les ans. Je vous ai dit qu'on avait
perdu 200000 Parisiens depuis 2001. Vous
avez des taux de vacances commerciales
sur certains axes. Vous prenez le
boulevard Saint-Michel, vous prenez
certaines avenues dans le 14e, vous
prenez la rue de Rennes, des commerces
qui ferment, des dépôts de bilan.
Terrible quand on voit ça,
parce que la ville se dévitalise. Vous
avez des classes qui ferment en plein
Paris.
Elle se dévitalise parce que ça devient
trop cher.
Voilà, trop cher et pénurie. vous pouvez
pas vous loger. Donc un, vous avez les
loyers qui continuent d'augmenter malgré
l'encadrement et de du fait de
l'encadrement, on a créé la pénurie. Il
faut absolument déplafonner les prix des
loyers. Et là, qu'est-ce qu'on observe ?
Est-ce que les loyers vont exploser d'un
coup ? Non. Pourquoi non ? Parce qu'en
réalité, ils ont continué d'augmenter. À
chaque fois qu'on essaie de brider
l'économie, l'économie se venge et elle
essae à toute force de montrer la vérité
des prix. D'où les contournements que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure.
Une question simple. Oui,
le prix des loyers pour 20 m² dans le
12e moi je vais je vais je vais arrêter
les cuises vraiment tous. Je me
répondrai la même chose maintenant par
même quand je connais je répondrai. Je
ne réponds plus au c
te fait piéger avec le passe navigo.
C'est ça. Ouais. Et j'ai regretté
d'avoir répondu et donc je me dis
maintenant je ah bah maintenant je suis
incollable he mais je vais arrêter avec
les quiz. C'est 90 mais je vais arrêter
avec les quiz. Stop stop par mois par
mois par moi. Je vais arrêter avec les
quiz vraiment. Donc je reprends juste
sur l'encadrement parce que là il y a il
y a une question majeure d'économie en
réalité. Àéoer quand Miley est arrivé,
il a déplafonné les prix des loyers. Il
a résolu la crise du logement en
Argentine.
Non seulement il a résolu la crise du
logement parce que les argentins ont pu
de nouveau se loger dans leur capital,
mais on a observé au bout de quelques
mois que les prix des loyers avaient
baissé. Il y a eu un tel choc d'offre
que les prix des loyers ont baissé. Et
ça c'est pas du libéralisme, c'est juste
de l'économie. Donc c'est ça que je
voulais faire comprendre, c'est que
demain quand on déplafonnera les prix
des loyers. Un non, il n'y aura pas
d'explosion parce qu'en réalité ça a
continué à monter de manière continue.
La vérité des prix a continué à
s'imposer par tous les détournements
possibles. Deux, on résoudra enfin ce
problème de la pénurie. Il y aura de
nouveau des biens à louer sur le marché
locatif. Donc ce qu'on peut au contraire
espérer, c'est qu'au bout de quelques
mois, les prix baissent, que les
Parisiens puissent de nouveau se loger,
que la classe moyenne parisienne puisse
de nouveau se loger. Il y a un énorme
sujet du logement. C'est pas qu'à Paris,
hein, je vous ai dit qu'il y avait
d'autres communes de France qui avaient
suivi et j'espère qu'il y en aura plus
d'autres et qu'on va comprendre avec
l'exemple parisien depuis qu'on l'a mis
en œuvre qu'en réalité ça ne marchait
pas. Une fois qu'on l'aura compris, on
donnera un exemple à tout le reste du
pays sur ce sujet comme sur les autres.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez à Paris ce qui se
dessine comme tendance, c'est que seuls
peuvent se loger à Paris soit des
catégories très aisées, soit des
retraités qui ont pu acheter à Paris à
un moment où on pouvait acheter, soit
des catégories qui connaissent quelqu'un
qui connaît quelqu'un à la mairie et qui
peuvent avoir une place dans un logement
social. Est-ce que c'est ça qu'on veut ?
Est-ce qu'on veut cette extrémisation
des cas de logement à Paris ou est-ce
qu'à l'inverse, on ne préfère pas une
ville dans laquelle la classe moyenne
peut se loger, les classes populaires
peuvent se loger comme c'était encore le
cas ? avant qu'on fasse 1 l'encadrement
des loyers de l'explosion des HLM à
Paris. Moi, je veux un système dans
lesquels vous dans lequel vous avez
énormément de biens qui reviennent sur
le marché locatif des pass des surfaces
euh trop petites.
Pourquoi pas forcément ? Là, les 50000
biens qu'on a perdu sur le marché
locatif, c'était pas des forcément des
passoirs thermiques. C'est simplement
une question de rentabilité pour les
propriétaires et c'est ce qu'on a
observé partout. Dès qu'on encadre les
prix des loyers, dès qu'on mine la
rentabilité, tout de suite vous avez des
baisses de demandes de permis de
construire. C'est ce qu'on observe
historiquement bas et un choc d'offre
négatif sur le marché locatif.
D'autres explications sur le les permis
de construire,
je vous en prie
les coût des matières premières.
Vous êtes venu avec un peu de
Mais encore une fois, c'est ce qu'on
observe partout où il y a eu un
encadrement des loyers. Donc il y a bien
un facteur.
Vous êtes venu avec des papiers parce
qu'en général je suis relativement
hardcore avec les sources.
Exact. Et je me suis parlé d'un truc
tellement gigantesque que je vous ai
demandé de venir avec vos sources.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Là tout à l'heure on parlait de
l'encadrement des loyers. Donc j'avais
les décrets et cetera. Mais alors là,
c'était pour le coup pour faire
comprendre un peu aux gens comment
est-ce que la mairie euh utilise
l'argent. Donc je vais vous lire des
intitulés réels des subventions de la
mairie de Paris et juste vous allez voir
donc là ce que je dis disponible en open
data sur le site de la mairie de Paris
et vous pouvez voir en même temps. Donc
j'ai tout téléchargé, j'ai épluché ça.
Vous avez des délibérations qui ont été
votées en conseil de Paris en 2025 et on
peut aller voir ça. Donc on parle pas de
rumeur, on parle pas de fake news, on
parle de documents officiels. Je vous
lis quelques-uns. Ça ça vaut son son pes
en d'or.
2500 € pour apprendre à caliner des
cochons d'Inde. Je vous lis la la
délibération mot pour mot. Développer la
coopération à travers des stages de
médiation par l'animal où les enfants
apprennent à découvrir des cochons
d'Inde. Délibération 2025 DDCT 108.
Je peux vous couper
1500 €.
Je peux vous couper ?
Ouais.
Peut-être que c'est important
d'apprendre gamin.
Alors on va laisser manipuler votre
communauté juger. Comme ça, je vous
laisse faire l'avocat du diable et je
vais laisser les gens se faire leur
propre avis. 1500 € pour des cours de
gymnastique adapté pour les seniors
LGBTQI
plus. L'association Galipette maintient
à un tarif abordable des cours de
gymnastique adaptés pour les seigneurs
LGBTQU plus des 11e et 18e
arrondissement. Là vous vous arrivez
même pas à faire l'avocat du diable.
Délibération 2025 des sols 55. On
continue. 3000 €
pour des clown enquêteurs. Là, ça va
être dur, hein. Je cite "Des
déambulations de personnages clownesques
pour renforcer le lien social à
Falgierre. Délibération 2025 DDCT 112.
Ça met de l'ambiance.
5000 €. Ça met de l'ambiance 5000 € pour
une radio qui n'ait qu'enré. Alors là,
ça met pas d'ambiance en France, ça met
de l'ambiance en héritrée. La radio
Erena s'oppose au régime en place
là-bas. C'est une cause louable en
effet. Mais est-ce que c'est au
contribuable parisien de payer pour une
radio qui n'aimait même pas à Paris ?
4000 € pour la fête de l'association des
amis et amis de la commune de Paris.
Donc une association qui célèbre la
commune de 1871 et qui est financée par
la mairie. Important. Alors moi ce que
je propose c'est que ces associations
soient financées par leurs généreux
donateurs et vous savez qu'en France
d'ailleurs quand vous faites un don à
une association il est déjà défiscalisé
à hauteur de 66 %. Je vous propose pas
de le faire pour ces associations-là,
mais il y a déjà une forme de solidarité
nationale qui existe. Moi ce que je
propose,
c'est de couper ces associ ces
subventions à des associations.
C'est des clopinettes ça.
Mais c'est important de comprendre la
philosophie quand vous Mais alors si si
vous si vous voulez qu'on trouve des
trucs qui sont avec des montants pour le
coût important, alors je vais lire la
suivante. Les Pierre de Lune, une
association censée promouvoir la
médiation artistique pour adoucir les
nuisances sonores nocturnes à Paris.
Depuis 2013, cette association a reçu
1243000
€ de la ville de Paris. Là, ça vous
choque, j'ai vu votre regard, n'est-ce
pas ?
Je suis pas choquée, je me dis qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire avec un million ?
Alors, en quoi consiste cette
association ? Voulez savoir ? Les Pierre
de nuit envoient des mimes sillonner les
terrasses pour rappeler aux gens de
faire moins de bruit. Des mimes 1,2
million d'euros d'argent public. Et
comme ça va vous plaire police dessus,
le Non, le président de cette
association s'appelle Emmanuel Coblance.
Il est conseiller municipal de Paris, un
élu Ça vous choque, un élu de la
majorité municipale qui préside une
association qui reçoit 1,2 million
d'euros. Il touche pas d'argent si
président
de la mairie. Voilà,
il touche pas d'argent.
Donc personne n'a rien dit sur ça
pendant des années. 1 million sur
combien ? Sur une année.
1 million de Je viens je viens de vous
le lire. Donc c'est depuis 2013.
2013. Vous avez donc des des
vous avez des mimes qui font comme ça je
suis dans les terrasses et qui touchent
ça. Moi la seule chose que je veux dire,
je pense que les gens se feront leur
avis eux-mêmes et j'ai même pas besoin
de de commenter ça, mais que aujourd'hui
il y a une nécessité de recentrer la
mairie sur ses propres. Attendez 2
secondes. Je dis pas du tout qu'elles
ont pas le droit d'exister. On peut pas
les interdire si elles veulent émettre
des radios. Enfin peu importe en fait.
Bien sûr qu'elles ont le droit
d'exister. Mais dans une ville où 84 %
des Parisiens estiment que la ville est
sale, dans une ville où on se sent de
plus en plus en insécurité, dans une
ville où on met parfois des mois pour
trouver une place en crèche pour ses
enfants. Est-ce que dans cette ville-là,
on a de l'argent à gaspiller ? Ne
serait-ce que 3000 € ? Est-ce que vous
préfériez pas que ces 3000 € servent à
augmenter le salaire d'une
professionnelle de la petite enfance par
exemple ? Est-ce qu'on préférerait pas
l'employé à autre chose ? Moi, je vous
dis pas je vous dis pas du tout que ces
associations sont pas utiles à
quelqu'un, qu'elles font pas plaisir à
quelqu'un. Si quelqu'un aime faire de la
gymnastique et qu'on l'aide, mais bien
sûr qu'elle le fasse.
Depuis 2013, est-ce que est-ce que il y
a eu une évaluation du résultat ? Parce
que si je me dis s'ils envoient des
mimes la nuit
pour dire bon bah vous faites pos une
très bonne question.
Est-ce que il y a eu forcément une
évaluation ? Il y a
vous posez une très bonne question. En
tout cas, moi c'est ce que je propose
dans mon programme. Moi, c'est ce que je
propose dans mon programme, c'est qu'il
n'y ait plus de subvention sans audit,
qu'on regarde les faits ou vous les
imiterez les mimes que il faut quand
même que les gens sachent pourquoi.
Parfois ça me fait sourire, fait des
imitations monsieur à la caméra. Donc
vous avez la nécessité en effet
d'auditer les subventions avant de les
reconduire. Aujourd'hui, il y a rien de
plus simple qu'obtenir une subvention de
la ville de Paris. Je crois avoir lu, je
mets des je crois quand j'en suis pas
sûre que une subvention sur deux était
acceptée par la ville. Donc quand vous
faites une demande, je veux même pas
donner le site parce que j'ai peur que
vous fassiez la tentative quand vous
faites une demande on n'est pas
subventionné d'ailleurs vous pouvez nous
sur Tip on touche aucune subvention on a
la TVA en dedans.
Il des mar au car de tour très bon sur
la pelodon.
Qu'est-ce que c'est les autres papiers
qui a par terre là ?
On va y venir. On va y venir. Il y a
plein de sources, il y a plein de
choses. Là c'était sur les loyers
capitalisés. On va y venir. Donc encore
une fois, je dis pas qu'il faut
interdire ces associations, elles ont le
droit d'exister. Elles font peut-être du
bien à certaines personnes, qu'elles
soient pas financées par l'argent des
Parisiens. Entre nous, c'est pas comme
si on roulait sur l'or. On n'est pas
Crésus pour aller distribuer de l'argent
comme ça. Vous avez dit là, il s'agit de
petite somme. Après, je vous en je vous
en ai donné des grosses. On pourrait en
donner des grosses pour d'autres
associations. Une association qui
s'appelle Aurore qui a touché 6,5
million d'euros. Bref, on pourrait
citer, attendez, on pourrait citer
beaucoup euh de montants comme ça, mais
moi, pourquoi je vous ai lu celle-ci ?
Pour montrer la philosophie, je pense
que les gens ont compris. C'est-à-dire
quand on écoute ça, il y a un côté on
est un peu écœuré. On se dit "En fait
cet argent, on aurait bien aimé le
mettre ailleurs." On manque tellement de
choses dans Paris. Il y a tellement de
sujets sur lesquels on sent qu'on
pourrait faire mieux. Parfois quand on
est, je sais pas si vous êtes motard,
mais parfois quand on roule sur des
routes parisiennes, alors on se dit euh
bon bah quand même euh euh il y a des
trous dans la chaussée. Est-ce que c'est
normal dans une ville comme Paris, je
dis pas que tout est de l'ordre de la
mairie, hein, mais il y a énormément de
sujets sur lequels on se dit mais
comment est-ce que l'État, les pouvoirs
publics, la mairie, les départements
peuvent gaspiller autant d'argent public
alors que c'est pas comme si on était à
la phase de luxe où tout va bien, où on
a plus besoin de rien et où les services
publics tournent naturellement. Donc une
fois de plus, il s'agit pas de les
interdire mais de dire ce n'est pas à la
collectivité de les financer. J'ai une
mesure dans mon programme qui vise à
dire que demain quand je serai maire de
Paris, j'interdirai les subventions aux
associations politisées. Et qu'est-ce
qui est une association politisée ? J'ai
fixé trois critères selon la méthode du
faisceau d'indice du Conseil d'État.
Premier critère, c'est une association
qui favorise la clandestinité,
l'illégalité. Si on favorise la
clandestinité, c'est normal qu'on ne
soit pas payé par la collectivité.
Encore une fois, elles peuvent exister.
Elles trouveront des donateurs qui
financeront. Deuxème critère, ce sont
des associations dont l'activité
principale est d'exercer des recours
contre l'État et les pouvoirs publics.
Quand on passe son temps, quand c'est
presque devenu l'activité majeure de
l'association, à attaquer des décisions
d'intérêt général, il est naturel que ce
ne soi pas les citoyens dans leur
ensemble qui vous financent. Dernier
critère pour juger d'une association
politisée, ce sont des associations qui
ont fait des appels à voter lors des
élections. Par exemple, les appels au
front républicain ou autres appelés à
voter pour tel ou tel parti au hasard
pour LFI. Quand on fait ça, ça veut dire
qu'on exclut certains français de son
domaine d'activité. Vous comprenez que
c'est anormal et injuste d'aller prendre
dans la poche de ces mêmes français de
l'argent par leurs impôts pour aller
financer ces associations. Moi, je
considère que c'est injuste. Par
conséquent, à ces associations là, on va
arrêter de donner des subventions. J'ai
fait un travail empirique. J'ai un
tableur Excel que je mettrai à votre
disposition si ça vous intéresse. Avec
6500 lignes, toutes les subventions qu'a
octroyé la mairie de Paris. Quand on
regarde les associations, si on fait le
travail empirique hein de regarder un
total de combien ? de 300 millions
d'euros par an en moyenne à des
associations. Le budget de dons aux de
subvention aux associations. Quand on
fait ce travail de regarder de manière
empirique, on arrive à un/3 des
subventions
données à des associations politisées.
100 millions.
Donc ça fait 100 millions. Vous êtes
fort, ça fait 100 millions d'euros
d'économie chaque année sur 10 an 1
milliard d'euros économisés sur les
subventions aux associations. Je vous
disais tout à l'heure que j'avais un
plan de 10 milliards d'euros d'économie.
qui me permettait de diviser par deux
tous les impôts locaux des Parisiens,
taxes foncières, taxes d'enlèvement des
ordres ménagères, taxes de balayage,
donc les impôts des propriétaires et les
impôts des locataires et de baisser les
tarifs de stationnement. Et j'ajoute, il
y a il y a une 5è chose et de baisser de
10 % ce qu'on appelle les frais de
notaire, les droits de mutation à titre
onéreux pour favoriser l'accès à la
propriété. Tout ça c'est financé par 10
milliards. Je vous ai déjà donné le
premier milliard. Je suis sûre qu'au
long de l'interview, on va réussir à
faire les 10 milliards si je vous donne
un chiffre, puisqu'on l'évoquait tout à
l'heure.
Arrêter la folle politique immobilière
de la ville qui consiste notamment à
préampter des logements, on en a parlé
au tout début, pour y installer des
logements sociaux, mais encore folle
politique immobilière de la ville qui
consiste à investir dans des
écoquartiers, dans des commerces
équitables. Ça
c'est quoi écoquartier ? Bah c'est c'est
un écoquartier comme son nom l'indique
et à mon avis ça n'est pas à la mairie
de le faire. La métier ne doit pas jouer
aux entrepreneurs. Le métier d'une
mairie, c'est d'assurer la propreté, la
salubrité, la tranquillité au terme du
code général des collectivités
territoriales. C'est ça le métier d'une
mairie. Pas de jouer aux entrepreneurs,
pas de faire des opérations immobilières
tous les ans. 500 millions d'euros tous
les ans d'opération immobilière, il faut
y mettre un terme. Ça ça fait 5
milliards d'économie sur 10 ans. On est
déjà à 6. Ensuite, je vous ai parlé de
diviser les effectifs de la ville de
Paris par deux à horizon de 10 ans. Là,
ça nous fait 3 milliards d'économies
nettes. Je dis nette parce que c'est en
comptant les nouvelles embauches de
policiers municipaux et les
professionnels de la petite enfance.
D'économie nette, c'est 3 milliards.
Donc là, on en est à 9. Et le dernier
milliard pour arriver à 10 milliards
d'économie, c'est en remboursant de
manière prématurée la dette. Grâce au
plan de vente de 10 % du parc social
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure. En
réussissant à rembourser la dette de la
ville de Paris de manière prématurée, on
économise 1 milliard. Aujourd'hui, le
service annuel de la dette, c'est 500
millions d'euros. 500 millions d'euros,
c'est plus que le budget de la police
municipale. C'est colossal. Donc en
réussissant à la rembourser de manière
prématurée, on économise encore 1
milliard, ça nous fait 10 milliards
d'économies sur 10 ans. Ça prend du
temps, j'avoue. J'aimerais dire qu'on
fait des économies le premier matin,
mais ce serait pas vrai et ce serait
démago. Cous, ce sera où ?
Alors, le dès le premier budget et c'est
pour ça qu'on a besoin de ce plan de
vente de logements sociaux pour pouvoir
avoir un budget en équilibre dès la
première année. D'ailleurs, je vous ai
ramené mon programme. Ce sera sur quoi ?
Les baisses d'impôts.
Non, les hausses.
Il y a pas de hausse d'impôts. Je les
baisse tous. Ah non, je vous ai cité les
impôts. Les impôts sur lesquels la ville
de Paris à la main. Vous avez la taxe
foncière, je la divise par de la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordres ménagers, je la
divise par de la taxe de balayage, la
divise par de les droits de mutation à
titre onéreux, je les baisse de 10 %
pour tous et je les exonère pour les
primaux accédents pour permettre l'accès
à la propriété. Et ensuite en recette,
vous avez les tarifs de stationnement et
je les baisse aussi. Donc là, je vous ai
ramené mon programme. Mon programme
c'est 130 pages. Ouais, je montre juste
la
voulez le papier. Vous aimez ça, vous
aimez bien les
Est-ce que le programme
le programme on va y revenir parce qu'il
y a la courbe budgétaire. Donc ici c'est
Pourquoi vous êtes habillé tout le temps
au jaune ? Que c'est un code couleur
jaune tout ça.
Pourquoi le code couleur jaune de du
livre programme et cetera ? Écoutez,
j'ai choisi le jaune parce que pour moi
ça symbolise mon programme ça s'appelle
une ville heureuse. Ça symbolise le
soleil au bout du tunnel. L'analyse que
j'ai faite c'était qu'aujourd'hui les
Parisiens, pourrait dire les Français
mais les Parisiens en particulier sont
malheureux. Ils sont tristes de voir
leur ville décliner. Ils voi une ville
qu'ils aiment qui est une ville hashtag
qui est très populaire,
c'est ça cache Paris.
Ça cache Paris. Ouais. Ouais, c'est
vrai. Triste sacage Paris.
Quand quand quand on a été voir sur
sacage Paris, les gens râent parce qu'on
a des nouveaux lampadaires tout moches
alors qu'il y avait un patrimoine de la
la feronnerie de Paris qu'on retrouve ça
vendu sur le Boncoin
à très cher.
C'est fou. euh que les touristes
chinois, on a été discuté avec des
touristes chinois pour savoir leurs
angoisses,
que le ministère des affaires étrangères
chinois a dit euh "Évitez de vous
travailler avec trop de cach, le
braquage de bus euh où il y a des
Chinois, les bagages, les arnaques."
avec
bah quand vous avez des youtubeurs qui
viennent à Paris et qui au bout de 48 he
sortent désenchanté, il venaient voir le
paris de leur rêve, le paris d'Amélie
Poulin et ils se retrouvent à avoir peur
de se faire voler leur téléphone, avoir
des vendeurs à la Soviette en dessous du
champ de Mars ou un autre sujet duquel
j'entends pas la classe politique parler
quand on va dans certains quartiers qui
sont des quartiers du cœur historique de
Paris et qu'on retrouve tout au long des
boutiques de souvenirs, des fast food,
des boutiques de téléphonie mobile avec
une absence totale de diversité
commerciale, on a le sentiment d'être
dans une sorte de Disneyland bon marché.
Les touristes ne viennent pas à Paris
pour voir des tourfel qui clignotent
dans toutes les enseignes. Quand ils
viennent à Paris, ils veulent voir
Paris. Donc ils veulent voir des
fromagers, des bouchées, enfin bref, une
vie normale, une vie naturelle d'une
ville qu'on aurait jamais dû cesser
d'être. On il y a on a aujourd'hui à
Paris les plus beaux musées, les plus
beaux monuments du monde. Mais Paris
n'est pas un musée. Paris c'est une
ville qui est faite pour les vivants et
une ville heureuse pour reprendre le
titre de mon programme, c'est une ville
dans laquelle on a envie de faire des
enfants. Avis
d'élever d'élever des enfants
pour faire des enfants, il faut un toit,
un toit pas trop cher.
Exactement. Et là, on revient à tous les
sujets qu'on a touché. Je finis Ouais.
Ouais. Bah franchement, vous avez
raison. Je pense qu'on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la mairie de Paris est le
meilleur contraceptif de Paris. Oui.
Non, vous avez raison. Il y a tellement
de cris,
il y a tellement de crises. La crise du
logement, l'insécurité, la saleté,
l'absence de place en crèche, au bout
d'un moment, il faut quand même que
quelqu'un soit responsable. Il y a pas
qu'un facteur. Quand vous parlez à des
Parisiens qui quittent Paris ou qui
envisagent de le faire, je vous donne un
exemple. Vous avez des communes
limitrophes, le Valois, Saint-Mandé,
Neïi, Vincenten, donc juste à côté de
Paris. vous y allez, il y a des
poussettes dans tous les parcs. Donc il
faut des Parisiens qui aient de la
chance qui peuvent se loger dans ces
communes limitroph mais dès que vous
traversez le périphérique, il y a des
poussettes partout, il y a de la vie, il
y a des écoles qui sont pleines et dans
le cœur de Paris, c'est le contraire, ça
se désertifie. Moi, je veux tout le
contraire. Je veux une ville heureuse,
donc une ville vivante. Il faut
retrouver des places en crèche. Grâce à
mon programme, on peut en retrouver 7000
des places en crèche avec l'embauche de
professionnel de la petite enfance. Ça
va coûter de l'argent mais grâce à un
plan d'économie de 10 milliards, on peut
le financer.
C'est quoi les petits papers ? Alors,
on va on je j'arrive j'arrive. J'étais
en train de vous dire les youtubeurs qui
viennent à Paris et qui s'attendent à
voir le paris de leurs rêve.
Pas n'importe quel type de youtubeur,
youtubeur de droite, dur anglais.
Ah non, pas fort. Ah, vous pensez à
Tommy Robinson ? Je pas moi je pensais à
des youtubeurs qui viennent du Japon qui
se filment dans les rues que d'ailleurs
je connais pas forcément
d'ailleurs
ouais mais donc toutes sortes de
youtubeurs même ceux qu'on connaît pas
mais qui font des buz sur TikTok parce
qu'ils mettent des vidéos de Paris et
cetera donc je pensais pas
nécessairement à un truc très politisé
des gens basiques qui viennent qui
filment leur
bah comment dire leur expérience
parisienne et qui disent "Mais ça ne
correspond pas du tout à ce à quoi on
s'attendait." Non seulement l'insécurité
mais pas que la saleté. Je vous ai parlé
des quartiers dans lesquels ils
s'attendent d'avoir Paris et il voit des
boutiques entières made in China, I love
Paris comme on retrouve partout. Il
pourrait être à Prague, à New York, ce
serait la même chose. Une perte
d'identité. Je veux qu'on retrouve ça.
On a tous les moyens de retrouver
l'identité parisienne. L'ambition de mon
programme, c'est la première page, c'est
de renouer avec le Paris éternel tout en
projetant Paris dans le Paris de 2050.
Il faut acheter à Paris maintenant.
C'est-à-dire bah si je suis élu vous le
saurez le 22 mars. Si si vous êtes élu,
le prix de l'immobilier risque
d'augmenter. Non.
Ben écoutez, si je suis élu le 22 mars,
je ferai tout pour que Paris soit une
ville heureuse dans laquelle on a envie
de vivre. Dis, est-ce que vous avez
discuté avec les autres partis
politiques concernant Paris, la France
ou autre chose ?
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire ?
Bah, vous avez débattu, vous avez
échangé.
Alors, pour l'instant, les autres
refusent le débat, ce que je trouve ce
que je trouve assez étonnant. Alors pour
vous citer les candidats, vous avez pour
le rassemblement candidat
elle refuse le débat ?
Non, elle jamais le débat. Non.
Bah je vous assure qu'elle refuse le
débat.
Vous az proposé ?
Ah, tout le monde lui a proposé. La
gauche, la droite. On lui a tous
proposé. Elle refuse le débat. Je vous
assure, aller voir sur internet. Mais
pour moi, c'est très étonnant. Pour moi,
la démocratie c'est le débat. Vous vous
souvenez d'ailleurs qu'on avait
tous les deux une riche idée. Vous aviez
une riche idée que j'avais accepté.
C'était ce débat avec Antoine Léoman. Je
vous ai vu euh
on était en train de vous chicorer le
nez sur internet.
Ouais.
Moi je me suis dit je vais les mettre
d'accord. Je connais la France
insoumise, je vous connais. Euh tout le
monde sait que on évite de se chicorer
chez nous mis à part quand il y a un
écologiste qui se prend le nez avec
quelqu'un de droite et qu'on nous tient
pour responsable. Mais normalement, on
fait des débats antinucléaires,
prononucléaires, ça se passe bien, les
gens échangent, tout se passe bien. Donc
je vous je je vous vois vous chicorer et
je vois votre l'autre protagoniste vous
chicorer dessus. Je me dis "OK, venez
faire un débat chez moi, on va
s'expliquer. Quand les gens se parlent,
ils évitent de se taper dessus, je
dirais."
et on nous a fait faubon et et je je
garde la chose un peu en travers de la
gorge parce que les propositions étaient
acceptées des deux côtés et puis plus
rien.
Et puis plus rien. Et puis monsieur le
disparu. Voilà. Ensuite, on a dit que
ils avaient accepté le débat mais
ailleurs.
Oui. Ouais. Ouais. Tout à fait. Il y a
une chaîne de télé qui m'a appelé et qui
m'a dit "Monsieur Léomont accepterait,
c'est sa hiérarchie chez LFI qui nous a
contacté. il accepterait mais si c'est
un débat très court donc manifestement
ça lui faisait peur de débattre
longtemps. Moi je suis je suis toujours
prête. Moi j'adore les débat je pense
que c'est ça la démocratie et que c'est
d'ailleurs le moment
le moindre des respect c'est un jeu de
mot avec Léom euh et que c'est le
moindre des respects qu'on peut accorder
au aux électeurs, au public.
C'est-à-dire que le respect à leur
accordé c'est de débattre sur le fond.
D'abord de proposer du fond. C'est pour
ça que j'ai fait cet effort. On en
reparlera. font aussi chez les filles
hein.
Justement, pourquoi ne sont-ils pas
prêts à l'opposition démocratique et au
débat ? En principe, on dit que le débat
public, ça doit avoir un effet
catartique. Ça doit ça veut dire que ça
doit purger des passions, ça doit purger
la société de ses violences. La
politique, ça doit servir à ça. On
s'oppose par des mots pour ne pas
s'opposer par la violence. Et
d'ailleurs, on remarque que tous ceux
qui sont les plus antiliberté
d'expression, liberticite, sont souvent
ceux qui deviennent violents. C'est
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
documenté.
qui dit moins on a de vocabulaire plus
on est violent il y a un lien entre le
fait de après le tremblement de terre
d'ailleurs les enseignants étaient morts
donc il y a eu des grands retardés et ça
a donné les effets de gang qu'on a vu
après.
Intéressant vous avez un lien entre la
volonté de ne plus passer par les mots
et le passage à la violence. Je suis
partisane pour purger la société de ces
violences de toujours accepter le débat.
fus avec quelqu'un avec lequel je ne
partage rien. Pour moi, Léoman, c'est un
robespiriste fou qui me mettrait au
goulag s'il était au pouvoir.
Mais pour autant, je veux bien débattre
avec lui parce que c'est intéressant.
Oh là là ! Bah alors, vraiment ni l'un
ni l'autre he. C'est pas possible de me
demander à choisir entre la peste et le
coléra. Vraiment ni l'un ni l'autre.
Donc débattre avec quelqu'un avec lequel
on n'est pas d'accord,
Mara, bah le la terreur enfin pour moi
c'est vraiment indéfendable. Donc
débattre avec quelqu'un avec lequel on n
pas d'accord être obligé de passer par
là. par la terreur.
Non.
Est-ce que vous avez pas l'impression
que les gens Est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression que les gens sur internet
il commencent à en avoir un peu ralbol
de la gabie politique,
du passage de plat des journalistes ?
Ils ont l'impression d'être abandonnés
de partout. On voit on voit des Micke et
Mouse gérer notre politique étrangère,
notre diplomatie. On les voit et il
commence en avoir un peu ralbol.
Ah oui. Est-ce qu'il y a un ralbol ?
Oui. Est-ce qu'il y a une colère ? Oui.
Absolument. France, on a une grande
tradition. C'est quand on vraiment on en
a marre
euh on leur explique un peu.
Est-ce qu'il faut faire une révolution ?
Oui. Est-ce qu'il faut faire la
révolution par les urnes ? Oui. Est-ce
qu'il faut promouvoir la violence ? Non.
On dit un prover sur internet en ce
moment qui dit croire dans le vote,
c'est comme croire à la lettre du père
Noël.
Ah bah ça je peux pas je peux pas être
d'accord avec ça. Croire dans certains
politiciens évidemment oui. On a vu où
ils nous ont conduit. C'est pour ça que
je suis partisane aujourd'hui d'être la
plus transparente possible dès le début,
de pas dire aux électeurs "Votez pour
moi et c'est un chèque en blanc." Et
vous verrez, faites-moi confiance, vous
verrez, j'ai un super caractère, j'ai du
tempérament. Vous savez, les
politiciens, ils vous disent beaucoup
"Votez pour moi parce qu'il suffit
d'avoir de la volonté politique." Non,
non, non, non. Il suffit pas. Il faut de
la volonté politique, c'est indéniable.
Mais il faut pas que ça. Il faut aussi
dire ce qu'on va faire. Il faut faire un
travail. Il faut montrer aux gens avec
des chiffres, avec des faits, il faut
leur dire où on les emmène. Il faut pas
leur dire "Faites-moi un chèque en blanc
et puis on verra demain. On verra quand
je serai élu". Vous avez aujourd'hui une
classe politique qui est passionnée
exclusivement par la conquête du
pouvoir. Donc ils sont parfois
compétents pour faire campagne et puis
après ils se révèlent incompétant tout
leur mandat. Moi, je suis passionnée par
l'exercice du pouvoir. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait demain ? Qu'est-ce que je fais
quand je suis à mon bureau de mer ?
Qu'est-ce que je fais le premier jour ?
Comment est-ce que je gouverne la ville
de Paris ? Comment est-ce que je veux
gouverner Paris avec son peuple ? comme
on gouverne la Suisse ? Comment est-ce
que je veux gouverner par référendum en
imposant au minimum deux référendums par
an sur les grands sujet pour que les
Parisiens puissent choisir comment
est-ce que je veux imposer que pour tout
projet d'aménagement sur la voirie de
plus que 100 millions d'euros, on soit
obligé de passer par référendum parce
qu'il faut consulter les gens. Et ça à
mon avis c'est la seule manière
aujourd'hui de purger la société de
cette défiance qu'ils ont cherché. Ils
ont bien creusé pour qu'on en arrive à
là à ne plus avoir confiance en rien. La
seule manière de renouer la confiance,
c'est que les gens décident pour
eux-mêmes. Et c'est pour ça que je suis
très partisane du référendum. Question
de questions. On a retrouvé les bijoux
du Louvre.
Mais il paraît qu'on les a retrouvé
déformé, défiguré par qui était tombé
par terre.
La blague c'est votre avis sur si ce qui
ce qui s'est passé au Louvre. Un
scandale et quand on voit qu'on a tenu
124 jours avec madame Laurence Descart
qui est resté à la tête du Louvre alors
que le Louvre avait été volé, braqué, la
risée du monde entier. Vous avez vu ce
braquage ? Les pieds ni clclés qui ont
braqué le Louvre, c'est la honte. On
parlait tout à l'heure des youtubeurs,
vous aviez des JT chinois, japonais,
coréens, évidemment américains qui
étaient effaré de voir que le louf
pouvait être braqué comme ça. Effarré,
c'est quand même ça, c'est le patrimoine
mondial. ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur du
Louvre, ça nous appartient mais on voit
bien que ça dépasse les frontières du
périphérique. Le monde entier se sent
concerné de ce qui s'est passé à Paris
et donc cette madame Laurence Descart,
elle est restée en poste et on lui a
refusé sa démission et elle est restée
irresponsable en fait. 124 jours, le
Louvre a été braqué. Ensuite, le Louvre
a été victime des intempéries. Vous vous
souvenez ? Inondation en plein cœur du
Louvre. Et donc là, on se dit "Mais en
fait, personne n'est responsable dans ce
pays, personne n'est responsable de
rien. Une dame comme ça, j'imagine
qu'autant de de Gaul le lendemain elle
démissionne ou le lendemain elle est
virée. C'est la moindre des choses. Là,
vous avez de tels manquements." Moi,
j'avais écrit une lettre au Premier
ministre.
Lequel ?
Il y a quelques jours à le cornu. Il y a
quelques jours, il y a 10 jours, j'ai
écrit une lettre. Tu es trahouette.
Son surnom. J'ai écrit une lettre au
Premier ministre en lui demandant la
démission de madame Laurence Descart. Il
se trouve que 2 jours après, elle
partait. Je sais pas si j'ai eu un
impact mais en tout cas ravi ravi que ça
ait été le cas parce que c'était bien
nécessaire après 124 jours d'impunité en
réalité et d'irresponsabilité. Donc on
se dit en effet que personne n'a l'air
responsable. Je reviens à la question du
débat. Je disais en principe le débat
politique ça doit permettre de purger la
société de ces violences parce qu'on
s'oppose par les mots et qu'on ne passe
pas par la violence. Vous avez un lien
entre des individus qui sont violents,
je pense aux antifas et qui sont les
mêmes, qui sont contre toute forme de
liberté d'expression.
Il y a un lien. Quand on refuse la
liberté d'expression, quand on refuse le
débat politique, à la fin on en vient au
main. C'est tout ce que je veux éviter,
je vous ouvre une parenthèse sur le
débat. Vous avez pas l'impression que
aussi les politiciens
insufflent du venin dans la
communication politique à s'invectiver,
à essayer de se piquer ?
C'est pour ça que je vous disais tout à
l'heure, il faut revenir sur le fond et
j'ai fait le lien entre le fait de
respecter les électeurs, d'être
transparent, de dire "Voilà ce que je
veux faire, tout est chiffré, tout est
budgé, ça s'améliore évidemment. Je dis
pas que c'est parfait et que maintenant
que j'ai fait ce document, il
s'améliorera pas. Je l'améliore tous les
jours. Il est en ligne sur
unvilleureuse.fr d'ailleurs. Je
l'améliore tous les jours en cont au
contact des Parisiens. On me soumet des
idées, je les expertise, je regarde avec
mon équipe. Quand je vois que c'est
pertinent, j'accepte de changer d'avis.
Encore une fois, j'ai pas la science
infuse. J'ai 32 ans, j'apprends tous les
jours. Quand quelque chose me paraît bon
d'intérêt général, je vais l'expertiser,
je vais regarder, ensuite, je vais
changer. Mais c'est le moindre dres
respectespect que de faire ce travail.
Quand je vois des candidats à la mairie
de Paris qui ont des programmes qui font
20 pages avec zéro chiffres à
l'intérieur, mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ça ? C'est un manque de respect.
C'est un manque de respect pour la
démocratie. La démocratie, ça suggère
d'être transparent en tant que candidat,
de dire "Voilà ce que je veux faire. Une
fois que je vous ai dit ça, j'accepte de
débattre projet contre projet et il
s'agit pas de s'invic. Dans ma campagne,
je pense qu'il y a une particularité,
c'est que j'ai été beaucoup pataqué,
beaucoup et
le coup du poste Vigo, c'était normal,
on va dire. J'aurais préféré ne pas me
tromper. On va dire comme le coût du
ticket de métro ou le prix de la
baguette,
on va dire. Mais il faut aussi
reconnaître qu'ils en ont profité comme
des malade. Alors je compte pas passer
la campagne à leur faire plaisir mais je
peux comprendre que ça leur ait fait
plaisir. J'ai pas été attaqué que sur
ça. En revanche, moi ce que j'ai dit
depuis le premier jour
que mes adversaires, ça n'étaient pas
les autres candidats. Mes adversaires,
ce sont les problèmes des Parisiens. Ce
sont les gabjgis, la saleté,
l'insécurité. C'est contre eux que je
veux me battre. C'est contre eux que je
veux gagner. Qu'est-ce qui se passe si
on s'attaque pas à ça ? On calculait,
on sait pas si c'est du 3 % les 10
milliard, mais bon, dans 25 ans,
imaginez-vous qu'on est 20 milliards de
dettes. H
on sera obligé de passer par quoi ? On
va vendre la tour Effel, on va vendre le
Louvre. C'est c'est intéressant que vous
disiez ça parce que quand on reproche à
aux socialistes leur gestion, ils disent
"Bah non mais regardez, le patrimoine
parisien c'est 47 milliards." Ça
sous-entend un peu ça. Ils se disent que
finalement la dette c'est pas si grave
parce qu'il y a un patrimoine en face.
Je veux pas du tout en arriver là. Je
pense que la la mairie va faire des
efforts. Elle va baisser son budget.
Elle va réussir à faire des économies de
10 milliards sur 10 ans. Grâce à ça, on
va baisser les impôts. Grâce à la vente
de 10 % du parc social, on va réussir à
diviser la dette de Paris par de et on
va pas en arriver à ces extrémités.
C'est très intéressant ce que ce que
vous dites par rapport au patrimoine
opposable à la dette.
Je vais faire quelque chose que on ne
fait jamais sur Syerview, mais je vais
quand même répéter ce qu'on a entendu
dans des bruits de couloir relativement
sourcés, relativement dans des
institutions suffisamment centenaires
pour que ça nous interpelle.
Il se sussure à l'oreille que pour
rembourser la dette de la France, on va
taxer 10 % du patrimoine brut des
Français.
C'est crédible, c'est pas crédible ?
Alors comme syw, je n'aime pas avancer
des choses que je ne sais pas de sources
sûr et sur lesquelles j'ai pas de
documents. Plusieurs sénateurs qui nous
ont parlé de ça.
Ce qui est crédible et là je vais vous
l'accorder, c'est que la philosophie
actuelle de toute la classe politique,
tout parti confondu, de LFI au RN en
passant par la Macronie, c'est de
toujours taxer plus pour que l'État
puisse continuer de dépenser plus. Il ne
s'oppose que sur une seule chose, quelle
va être la prochaine cible de la folie
fiscale ? Et quand vous avez entendu à
l'automne dernier les débats à
l'Assemblée nationale, vous vous
apercevez que leur seul point de clivage
c'était qui doit être le nouveau book
émissaire. Alors pour un tel, ça doit
être les retraités, pour un autre, ça
doit être les holdings, pour un autre
les super riches, pour un autre les
ultra riches, pour un autre les classes
moyennes, et cetera et cetera. Et donc
ils se sont écharpés juste pour savoir
qui était le bon nouveau bouqu
émissaire. LFI et le RN ont dit les
multinationals, après c'était les
holdings, après le lendemain c'était un
autre, après c'est Bernard Arnaud. Donc
on va s'opposer juste pour savoir qui
est le prochain chez qui on va aller
faire les poches. Ce que je veux dire
c'est que aujourd'hui la France n'a pas
un problème de recette. Le problème
c'est pas qu'on n'a pas assez de
recettes puisque je vous disais qu'on
avait le taux de prélèvement obligatoire
le plus élevé du monde. 47 % de
prélèvement obligatoire. L'argent, il
est là, il existe puisque c'est vous qui
le produisez et qu'on le prend dans
votre poche. 47 %.
On n pas un problème de recette. Mais
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a comme problème ?
On a un problème de dépense, c'est qu'on
a aussi le taux de dépense le plus élevé
du monde. On dépense énormément, on
dépense sans compter. C'est là la clé du
mystère, c'est qu'on prend énormément
d'impôts et que pourtant on est très
endetté. Et c'est même quand on augmente
les impôts, on ne se désendte pas.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on dépense sans
compter. Si je vous prends une petite
métaphore, si vous avez un homme
avant la métaphore, si je vous dis qu'on
est obligé d'emprunter 300 milliards
pour faire 0,9 % de croissance,
bah c'est un chiffre qui est
catastrophique et qui montre l'ampleur
de ce cercle vicieux dans lequel on est
entré alors qu'on pourrait faire une
croissance bien plus importante tout en
se désendettant en baissant les impôts.
Même philosophie que ce que j'ai décrit
pour Paris avec une ampleur évidemment
bien plus élevée vu les montants pour la
France. Je vais vous dire avec quelle
philosophie on peut réussir à le faire.
J'étais en train de vous dire petite
métaphore. Si vous avez un homme,
mettons qui gagne très bien sa vie là ou
une femme, je prends la métaphore d'un
homme si vous voulez, on va prendre
celle d'une femme, je vais prendre celle
d'un homme parce que sinon vous allez
dire qu'à la fin, il y aura un un
préjugé. Donc un homme qui gagne très
bien sa vie, mettons quelqu'un qui gagne
5000 € par mois, dès qu'il reçoit sa
paye, il dilapide son argent. On se dit
"Mais comment faire ?" Il s'endettent,
il dilapide son argent. On sent bien que
cet homme, son problème, c'est sa
manière d'utiliser son argent et que
c'est pas parce qu'on va l'augmenter que
le problème va se résoudre. On sent bien
qu'il a pas un problème de recette cet
homme. Il a un problème de dépense. Il
dilapide sans compter. Si on l'augmente
et qu'on le met à 6000 € il dépensera de
la même manière. C'est exactement la
manière dont se conduit l'État français.
On pourrait augmenter le taux
d'imposition jusqu'à demain. C'est la
manière de dépenser l'argent qui pose
problème. Ce que je vous dis, ça a l'air
simple, ça a l'air banal, mais c'est
toute une philosophie. Aujourd'hui, la
philosophie des politiciens encore une
fois du RN jusqu'à la France insoumise
en passant par les centristes et les
macronistes, c'est de taxer plus pour
que l'État puisse dépenser plus. Ma
philosophie, c'est l'exact inverse. Je
renverse cette logique. Il faut dépenser
moins pour pouvoir taxer moins pour que
les Français gagnent plus. Donc, il faut
un plan d'économie massif qui est tout
de suite répercuté en baisse d'impôts.
Et grâce à ça, on va retrouver des
marges de manœuvre pour rembourser la
dette. Et c'est la différence entre deux
méthodes. La méthode du FMI qui ne pense
qu'au créancier et la méthode que je
propose, celle utilisée par Miley, mais
on pourrait dire avant même M et sans
avoir besoin d'aller jusqu'en Argentine.
La méthode qui avait été utilisée par
Jacques Ruf et par le général de Gaul en
58. La méthode FMI, quelle est-elle ?
C'est pas la mienne. Elle ne pense qu'au
créancier.
Donc il s'agit de dépenser moins mais
aussi de taxer plus. C'est quoi une
dette senior et une dette junior ?
Augmenter, j'ai dit plus de quiz.
D'augmenter les recettes
en augmentant les impôts, en vendant des
actifs, on parlait du patrimoine et de
baisser les dépenses. Comme ça, on va
rembourser la dette. Mais là, vous
connaissez la formule, le remède peut
tuer le malade. On peut asphhixier
l'économie, on peut rentrer dans une
période de stagnation. Bref,
le malade est mort guéri.
C'est exactement la formule. Ouais. On
peut tuer le malade. À l'inverse, la
méthode que je suggère, c'est de baisser
les dépenses pour tout de suite les
répercuter en baisse d'impôts. On fait
repartir la croissance, on libère
l'économie. Là, on a de nouvelles
recettes. Si on connaît un tout petit
peu la courbe de l'affaire et qu'on sait
que parfois quand on baisse le taux
d'imposition, les recettes augmentent
parce que l'assiette est plus large.
Donc l'économie repart et là, on a des
marges de manœuvre pour rembourser la
dette. Je disais, j'ai agruf, je finis
sur ça.
Si on l'augmente trop, les gens se
barrent. C'est exactement ça la courbe
de l'affaire. Ça montre que plus vous
augmentez le taux d'imposition, plus
jusqu'à un certain moment les recettes
vont augmenter. Mais arriver à un
certain point qui est le seuil euh de du
moment où finalement l'assiette va
commencer à se rarifier à cause de
l'augmentation des impôts. Là vos
recettes vont baisser alors même que le
taux augmente. Courbe de l'affaire 58.
Le général de Gaul arrive au pouvoir. On
est en pleine garde d'Algérie.
Mais on est aussi en pleine banqurroe.
Plus personne veut prêter à la France.
Aujourd'hui, on l'a oublié. Pourquoi ?
Parce que 6 mois plus tard, c'était
résolu. Grâce au général de Gaulle et à
l'action d'un homme, Jacques Ruf, ils
arrivent au pouvoir. En 6 mois, ils
baissent les dépenses publiques de 14 %.
Ils font repartir l'économie française
comme jamais. Le général de Gaul tient
un discours aux Français en leur disant
les taux étaient à combien à l'époque ?
plus de quiz, on va se retrousser les
manches.
Vous allez travailler mais vous allez
être fier de ce que vous allez
construire et vous allez percevoir les
fruits de ce que vous allez construire.
La pression était à combien à l'époque ?
Même réponse, on va pas vous demander de
vous sacrifier. On vous demande pas le
sacrifice. On vous demande de travailler
à nos côtés, de faire un effort pour le
pays. Et là, qu'est-ce que vous avez ?
l'industrie florissante, le nucléaire,
on arrive à créer un pays prospère et
magnifique et les Français envoient tout
de suite la couleur, ils s'enrichissent,
on a un essort, on a une classe moyenne
florissante, on arrive à équiper les
ménages avec les meilleures
technologies. Bref, on a une très belle
période de croissance en France alors
qu'il était arrivé avec un pays à l'état
de banoute. C'est un système qui a
fonctionné. Il y a pas parfois pas
besoin d'aller voir bien à l'étranger
quand on a ce genre d'exemple. Et encore
une fois, je vous disais l'exemple de
Miley. Il arrive à la tête d'un pays
avec une inflation énorme. Il fait un
plan d'économie massif, on connaît. Il
baisse les impôts, il fait repartir
l'économie, il déplaf état. Les
États-Unis ont un peu aidé derrière
les États-Unis. Vous parlez en terme
monétaire.
Ouais. Pour les États-Unis, j'avoue que
quand je regardais le système américain,
j'avais un peu de curiosité et d'espoir
de voir ce qu' allait réussir à faire
Musk avec le Dodge. Aujourd'hui,
j'estime que les résultats sont un peu
mitigés si on parle de leur 200
milliards, on on en rêverait vu nos
ordres de grandeur. On n pas le on n pas
le les mêmes les mêmes ordres de
grandeur. On en rêverait mais c'est en
de ça de ce qu'il avait lui-même prévu.
Donc j'imagine queon peut toujours faire
mieux. En tout cas, moi ce chat de
regarder avec honnêteté en me disant
qu'est-ce qui peut s'appliquer à la
France ? Qu'est-ce qui est positif pour
nous à l'inverse ? Qu'est-ce qui
correspond pas à notre histoire qui
marcherait pas chez nous et de voir ce
qu'on peut appliquer.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur ces fameux petit
papi que vous nous avez emmené ?
Alors,
on va passer à d'autres sujets. Alors,
alors ça c'est tout sourcé, tout carré.
Exactement. Donc là, il y a ce que je
vous ai lu sur les délibérations et les
fameux montants ahurissants que je mets
à disposition, que je publierai
certainement. J'invite aussi les gens
qui nous écoutent à aller sur
argentarisiens.fr
pour aller suivre l'enquête que j'ai
faite sur les compte de Paris. Là, j'ai
une autre affaire donc qui concerne le
périscolaire à Paris. Vous en avez
peut-être entendu parler. Vous avez
entre donc 2023 et 2025 animateurs à
Paris qui ont été suspendus pour
suspension pour pour suspicion pardon
d'agression sexuelle sur des enfants.
Sur combien d'animateurs total ? Donc
vous avez aujourd'hui dans le
périscolaire parisien un grave problème
qui est qu'on a le sentiment depuis
maintenant quelques mois puisque ces
affaires sortent dans la presse qu'il y
a eu une omerta pendant des années à la
ville de Paris avec des gens qui
savaient qui n'ont rien dit qui savaient
qu'il y avait ces suspicions d'agression
sexuelle sur des enfants
qui ont demandé parfois de ne pas
ébruiter les affaires.
dans de très nombreux arrondissements,
vous avez un journaliste du Parisien
avant Noël qui a tenté de piéger
la municipalité en essayant de se faire
passer pour un animateur qui voulait
être recruté en disant qu'il avait le
BAFA, on n'a pas contrôlé et le
lendemain, il était au contact des
enfants.
Il a pas fourni son diplôme.
Il a pas fourni son diplôme. Il a dit
qu'il en avait. Le lendemain, il a
réussi à entrer au contact des enfants.
Ça c'est un journaliste du Parisien qui
a publié ensuite son enquête et il a
fait cette tentative pour montrer le
laxisme aujourd'hui.
Donc vous avez des cas dans le
périscolaire parisien qui se multiplient
et un véritable traumatisme des parents.
Parce que quand on entend des affaires
qui remontent à 2016, donc il y a 10
ans, vous vous dites
peut-être qu'il est arrivé quelque chose
à mon fils, à ma fille qui me l'a jamais
dit et je le saurai jamais.
Quand vous avez un enfant jeune de 3
ans, généralement c'est difficile de les
faire parler. Quand à la fin d'une
journée, vous demandez comment s'est
passé la journée. Bon bah il disent
expliquer
non pas encore. Mais cette affaire à mon
avis ne va faire que monter en ampleur.
J'ai écrit au garde des saut Gérald
Armanin. Je lui ai écrit une lettre pour
lui demander de faire toute la lumière
sur ce qu'il avait. Est-ce qu'il est au
courant euh de de du fait que la justice
a pu être saisie à un moment ? Gérald,
il répond à chaque fois. Il vous a dit
quoi ?
J'ai pas une réponse. J'attends.
J'attends la réponse. Je lui redemande
officiellement. Je je demande au garde
des sauts de bien vouloir me répondre
sur cette affaire extrêmement grave qui
crée un traumatisme réel chez les
parents. Parce que non seulement on se
dit que ça peut encore avoir lieu, il
faut il faut imaginer 2 minutes ce que
c'est. Le matin, vous emmenez vos
enfants à l'école et puis pour le reste
de votre journée, l'école c'est une
sorte de boîte noire. Vous savez pas ce
qui s'y passe. Ça doit être un tiers de
confiance l'école. Quand vous laissez
votre enfant aux portes de l'école,
ensuite vous allez faire votre journée
et imaginez qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez des dizaines de milliers de
parents parisiens qui ont une boule au
ventre toute la journée qui se demandent
ce qui se passe, qui se demandent s'il
va pas arriver quelque chose à leur
enfant, qui se demandent quel est
l'étendue des dégâts, qui peuvent même
se poser des questions. Est-ce qu'il y a
un réseau qui a infiltré l'école ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Pourquoi autant ?
52 animateurs suspendus, ça fait
beaucoup.
Vous pensez à quoi comme réseau ?
Sincèrement, je sais pas. Je je pose la
question, c'est pour ça que j'ai demandé
des réponses aux gardes des sauts. Quand
je sais, je dis. Quand je ne suis pas
sûre, je n'avance pas. Donc, je me
contente de poser la question. On se
demande,
c'est un réseau pédophile.
Est-ce que On se demande 52 animateurs,
c'est quand même quelque chose. On se
demande qu'est-ce que c'est ? Pourquoi
autant pourquoi autant de cas ? Que se
passe-t-il à l'école à Paris ? Il y a
combien d'animateurs au total dans
Je vais plus répondre vraiment à des
quiz et même quand j'aurai la réponse,
je vais m'y tenir.
Quand vous avez autant de cas qui se
multiplient, quand vous entendez, on a
signalé à telle mairie, il y a des
parents à l'école Saint-Dominique dans
le 7e arrondissement, vous avez 73
parents qui ont saisi le procureur. Vous
avez des dizaines de parents qui s'en
plaignent, qui sont traumatisés, qui
disent qu'on leur a demandé de pas
ébruiter l'affaire, qui disent que
depuis des années finalement on leur a
pas donné de réponse. Moi ce que je dis
à partir de demain et ce sera la
première action en tant que mère parce
que c'est l'urgence, parce que c'est le
traumatisme
1. Contrôle régulier de l'inscription au
fichier des agresseurs sexuels. Et je
suis même choquée de le dire parce que
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on le fait
pas. Vous avez une mairie de gauche qui
gouverne avec les écologistes pour qui
en principe le principe de précaution
c'est quelque chose de majeur.
Pas pour la prunelle de nos yeux, pas
pour nos enfants. Pour moi, le principe
de précaution sera appliqué à la lettre,
c'est-à-dire qu'au moindre soupçon, à la
moindre phrase d'un enfant, au moindre
signalement d'un parent. On renvoie
immédiatement l'animateur. Il est
suspendu. Il n'a plus à mettre un pied
devant l'école des enfants.
Premier élément, principe de précaution.
inscription au fichier des agresseurs
sexuels qu'on contrôle de manière
périodique. Ensuite, à chaque fois que
je parle avec des parents parisiens, je
leur pose la même question : "En qui
est-ce que vous avez le plus confiance
pour la garde de vos enfants ?" Et ce
qui revient le plus souvent, c'est les
grands-parents. Je considère qu'il y a
un vivier énorme à Paris de personnes
âgées qui se sentent parfois seuls, qui
peuvent avoir des problèmes en terme de
pouvoir d'achat, de revenu avec une
petite retraite. C'est un vivier énorme.
On pourrait faire rappel à eux. C'est un
vivier de bienveillance. C'est un vivier
de transmission. peut-être être retraité
tranquille.
Alors, j'ai posé la question comme je
vous ai dit avant de construire un
programme, je parle aux gens. J'ai posé
la question à des grands-parents. Est-ce
que vous si on faisait appel à vous, que
vous puissiez être payé à la vacation ?
Vous devenez pas fonctionnaire ? Bien
sûr, vous êtes payé à 1 heure à 1 heure
par je je vous dis que mes échanges et
comment j'en suis abouti à cette mesure
et après je vais vous dire comment on
pourrait la mettre en œuvre. Ils me
répondent pour pour ceux à qui j'ai posé
la question et j'espère qu'il y en aura
d'autres. Ce sera un appel volontaire he
bien sûr, personne sera obligé de le
faire. Quand je demande à des
grands-parents, est-ce que vous seriez
prêt le mercredi après-midi à donner 4h,
5h où vous êtes devant les enfants, vous
racontez des histoires, ils me disent
"Mais on adorerait, on adorerait, on
verrait comment notre petitfils est avec
ses copains, comment notre petite
filorte à l'école." On adorerait faire
ça. Et bien sûr, je parle de l'animation
dans le périscolaire. Donc pour des
jeunes enfants de 3 ans à 6 ans, je
parle pas de changer des couches,
d'avoir de la force physique et cetera.
Je parle de quelques heures dans la
semaine à donner auprès de ces
petits-enfants. Si vous êtes parents,
que vous savez que aujourd'hui vous avez
une ADSEM que vous connaissez, mais en
plus la grand-mère d'une des copines de
votre petite fille ou de votre fille, ça
vous rassure, vous vous dites "Il y a
comme ça un un de bienveillance dans
cette classe. Il y a une forme de
surveillance parce que quand même on a
besoin d'être rassuré aujourd'hui, on en
est là."
Donc ça rassure tout le monde. Je
considère que c'est un vivier auquel on
fait pas assez appel et on pourrait le
faire demain. Oui.
L'authentification de l'âge sur les
réseaux sociaux pour les gens de moins
de 15 ans, c'est quoi votre avis ? Bah
je suis contre. Euh je me suis senti
bien seule à être contre. Je dirais que
en tant que parent, je suis favorable à
interdire les réseaux sociaux à mes
enfants avant qu'ils aient 15 ans. Mais
en tant que parent, j'entends pas que
l'État le fasse à ma place.
1, on a un état qui a passé son temps à
délégitimer l'autorité des parents, qui
prétend à devenir un état nounou qui
fait tout à la place des parents.
Aujourd'hui, dire queon va interdire les
réseaux sociaux au moins de 15 ans, ça
équivaut comme vous venez de le dire à
contrôler tout le monde. Comment vous
allez savoir si j'ai plus ou moins de 15
ans ? Donc on va pos
la question avec vous. Non
32, ça va, j'en suis j'en suis loin.
Mais c'est c'est très flatteur. La
prochaine c'est l'âge du Christ, hein.
Écoutez,
je ne sais pas. où j'en serai j'espère à
mon bureau à l'hôtel de ville avec les
premiers résultats qui auront déjà été
atteints pour les Parisiens.
Donc on on devra contrôler tout le
monde. On devra associer
un nom d'utilisateur sur les réseaux à
une carte d'identité. Vous voyez comme
moi les millions de fuites utilisateurs
tous les jours qu'on observe. Est-ce que
l'État français est capable ?
Vous avez une communication
ministérielle par
une excuse. Vous avez une excuse ? Un
mail. Je vous donne un exemple. Page
emploi, c'est le site sur lequel tous
les parents inscrivent leur garde
d'enfants et cetera. Ce site là a été
hacké. Vous imaginez ? Vous avez le nom
de vos enfants de ti aussi hein.
C'est c'est fou l'incapacité de protéger
nos données et pourtant on veut en
stocker de plus en plus. Je pense au
secteur des cryptos. Vous vous aviez
reçu d'ailleurs Pierre Noisa.
Aujourd'hui, il est à mes côtés. Pierre
Noisa, c'est ma tête de liste dans le
11e arrondissement. Disons pour ceux qui
nous écoutent mais qui le connaissent
très certainement s'ils suivent
Syerview. Polytechnicien brillant,
pionnier du Bitcoin en France. qui
aujourd'hui est ma tête de liste dans le
11e parce que ce que j'ai souhaité faire
dans cette élection, c'est promouvoir
une liste qui ne soit pas une liste de
professionnels de la politique mais de
professionnels de la réussite sans
mauvais jeux de mots qui connaissent
l'économie réelle qui ont des solutions
pour les Parisiens, qui aiment Paris,
qui veulent résoudre les problèmes des
Parisiens et pas, comme je le disais
tout à l'heure, des professionnels des
campagnes qui après la campagne se
révèlent incompétent et inexistants.
Donc liste de la société civile à mes
côtés et j'en suis très fier. Je ferme
cette parenthèse sur Pierre Noisa, les
réseaux sociaux contre cette
interdiction par l'État pour le fait que
les parents réussissent à euh à
interdire eux-mêmes à leurs enfants
d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que on sait que ça a des conséquences
qui peuvent être négatives en terme de
concentration, de suivi des cours et
évidemment que c'est essentiel et c'est
pas moi qui dirait que suivre à l'école,
s'informer, se cultiver au maximum,
c'est c'est évidemment essentiel. Donc
le fait que ça vienne de l'État me fait
peur. Je trouve que c'est une pente
liberticide. J'observe la même tendance
désormais avec les jeux vidéo et on sait
que ça va aller comme ça. Emmanuel
Macron euh qui décide que qui décrète
que les jeux vidéos rendent violents et
que c'est ça qui crée une société
violente. Si on regarde les pays où on
joue le plus aux jeux vidéos, la Corée,
le Japon, on n pas vu les mêmes émeutes
urbaines en Corée et au Japon que ce
qu'on retrouve chez nous. même culture.
Bah justement donc on voit bien que le
facteur c'est pas le jeu vidéo
puisque à culture différente, il devrait
se passer la même chose si c'était un
phénomène psychologique qui touche les
êtres humains tous de la même manière.
On observe que ça n'est pas le facteur.
Donc manifestement, monsieur Macron
cherche tous les moyens pour pouvoir au
maximum
bah
est-ce que c'est pour ça ? Est-ce que
c'est l'objectif ? En tout cas, ce sera
la conséquence. Vous
vous regardez un peu les autres pays
de l'Angleterre jusqu'à l'Australie.
Ça ressemble à un dispositif qui tombe
en même temps dans beaucoup de pays dit
civilisés. Hm
hm.
Euh c'est parce que ils veulent
s'initier dans l'éducation de nos
enfants ou c'est parce que ils
s'attendent à ce que ça il y a une
gronde sociale qui monte et cette gronde
sociale nécessiterait un encadrement un
peu plus pêchu.
Je ne connais pas l'intention par
définition mais je sais que ce sera la
conséquence. La conséquence, ce sera
d'avoir plus de moyens de surveillance,
de masse. Est-ce que c'est pour les
utiliser qu'ils font ça ? Pas la
réponse. Est-ce que ça leur en donnera
les moyens ? La réponse est oui. Est-ce
que ça me fait peur ? Oui. En tant que
personne attachée aux libertés publiques
? Évidemment, oui. Donc contre cette
mesure d'interdiction et même si on est
que quelques-uns et même sils ont réussi
à mettre dans la tête des gens que
c'était une mesure favorable, vous avez
vu les sondages comme moi, vous avez
plus de 70 % des Français qui sont pour.
Moi, je considère que si on éétait pas
là, si on ne s'y opposait pas, bah ce
serait 100 %. Donc évidemment qu'il faut
continuer et évidemment qu'il faut
toujours dire ce que l'on pense, quels
que soient les sondages et pousser
par conviction pour convaincre. À la
fin, le peuple a toujours le dernier
mot. Donc notre objectif, en tout cas le
mien, c'est toujours de convaincre. Et
d'ailleurs en politique comme un
économie, je suis plutôt partisane de la
politique de l'offre, c'est-à-dire je
réfléchis, j'essaie de construire mes
conviction et ensuite je propose.
Parfois c'est en adéquation totale avec
ce que pense l'opinion publique à
l'instant té, parfois non, mais je vois
ça comme un travail de conviction. C'est
mon rôle de convaincre. Sur la taxe
Zucman par exemple, j'y étais totalement
opposé. J'ai vu que 80 % des Français y
étaient favorables. J'étais triste de
voir ce chiffre
après un battage médiatique. Gogo,
voilà, c'est ce que j'allais vous dire.
J'étais triste de voir ce chiffre mais
je me suis dit bien sûr Zucman matin
TF1, midi France 2, après-midi France 3,
matin lendemain matin France 4, France
5, on le démaquillait plus.
Il a passé sa vie sur toutes les
antennes du service public. C'était
aberrant à quel point on l'a accueilli
partout jour et nuit. Donc évidemment
que si on vous avait mis vous, si on
m'avait mis moi tous les jours sur
toutes les antennes,
moi on me met pas moi.
Bah voilà. Donc si on nous avait mis
nous sur toutes les antennes, peut-être
que il y aurait pas eu 80 % de favorable
à la taxe Zukman.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans les autres
papiers ? On n pas été très nombreux, je
vais y venir, on n pas été très nombreux
à s'opposer à l'attaque zuman que j'ai
observé c'est que 2 semaines plus tard,
c'était plus 80 % mais 60. Donc ça sert
à quelque chose de mener des batailles
politiques et parfois on n'est pas dans
le sens du vent mais ça sert à quelque
chose parce que sur le long terme quand
on est force de conviction quand on se
dit que quoi qu'il arrive notre rôle
c'est de dire ce que l'on pense et pas
ce que les sondages disent à un instant
t alors je suis convaincu qu'on peut
gagner des batailles et je le pense sur
tous les sujets que ce soit l'économie
les sujets d'éducation culturelle
j'étais en train de vous parler du
périscolaire donc sur le périscolaire
écoutez j'avais des témoignages j'ai pas
envie de mettre une mauvaise ambiance.
Donc je les publierai. J'ai pas envie de
mettre une mauvaise ambiance en vous
lisant
je vais je vais Ouais, on est d'accord.
Je pense que c'est très très dur. C'est
très dur à entendre. C'est très dur à
entendre pour les parents ce qui se
passe dans l'école de leurs enfants.
Donc écoutez, l'essentiel, je vous l'ai
dit, ça m'a fait grand plaisir
d'échanger avec vous.
L'essentiel des papiers là, il fini.
Ouais, absolument. J'avais les sources.
Il y a pas de détail. Il y a pas de
détails sur le marché immobilier, qui a
pris quoi, qui comment. Non,
écoutez, j'ai beaucoup de sources.
C'était surtout pendant que je parlais
pour avoir à disposition pour pouvoir
les citer argentarisiens.fr.
Ça ressemble à quoi sans les
désanonymiser ? Ça ressemble à quoi les
témoignages ?
Les témoignages ? Bah à ce que ce qu'ils
ont ce qu'ils ont entendu de leurs
enfants, à ce qu'ils ont découvert
parfois après des années. Là on parle si
si on parle du du périscolaire, c'est
non, c'est terrible. C'est les écoles
qui sont concernées, les
Ouais.
Écoutez, ça c'est c'est un sujet qui est
assez assez dur en réalité.
Bah ouais,
on voit
question internet. Je prends la première
en la découvrant avec vous. Que
répondez-vous à ceux qui malgré vos
discours plein de bon sens soulignent
votre parcours ultra formaté entre
parenthèses Sorbon IEP et fermé la
parenthèse et vous perçoivent comme une
éème déclinaison de des responsables
politiques de tout bord qui ont mené la
France au bord du gouffre.
Bah, j'essaie de prouver que je ne suis
pas que la somme des des écoles que que
j'ai faites. Je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure de ceux avec lesquels j'essaie
de de m'entourer au maximum. Euh, ils
ont pas forcément fait les mêmes écoles
que moi. Moi, je suis beaucoup entourée
d'ingénieurs, j'en avais parlé la
première fois qui ont pas fait Science
Poil Lena. Ça m'aide aussi cette
complémentarité à réfléchir, à
travailler, à découvrir des domaines qui
sont pas forcément les miens mais qui
sont tout aussi passionnants. Euh par
ailleurs et peut-être un élément
intéressant, moi je suis une fille de
commerçant donc qui vient je dirais de
l'économie réelle qui sait que un sous
est un sous, un client est un client,
voilà.
Une compta une compta.
Exactement. Et quand je suis arrivée à
Lena, la première chose, je me souviens
qu'avait demandé le directeur à
l'époque, c'était lever la main ceux qui
ont des parents fonctionnaires dans la
pièce et presque toute la salle avait
levé la main.
On a le droit de faire ça ?
Ouais, bien sûr pour une enquête CSP
quoi. Et on on pose souvent ces
questions aux gens, la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle des parents et
cetera à l'école. En tout cas, ça a
intéressé tout le monde. Donc bon, il a
posé la question, ça a pas choqué et il
avait dit "Et qui a des parents
commerçants ?" J'étais la seule à lever
la main et ça faisait un peu plou des
parents commerçants. Vous savez que
Margarette Tetcher était une fille
d'épicier. Alors mon père était pas
épicsier mais quand même ça faisait un
peu Margarette comme idole.
Euh idole c'est un trop grand mot
d'avoir une idole mais comme je vous ai
dit je remarque je regarde beaucoup ce
qui s'est passé dans le monde et j'aime
bien les moments de rupture politique.
On passe d'un système à l'autre pour
voir comment est-ce que la société rége
et qu'est-ce qui pour nous est bon à
reprendre. Qu'est-ce qu'il y a à
l'inverse ? Ben, on voit que ça a pas
fait des effit que des que des bonnes
choses.
C'est exactement ce que je vous dis.
Donc, j'essaie de regarder tous les pays
mais plutôt comme une étude de marché
que comme une admiration sans borne en
disant "Ah ouais, je suis fan de Trump
ou de M, je suis pas fan." Non, c'est
pas je parle pas en tant que fan mais en
tant que personne qui essaie de tout
étudier, le modèle suisse, comment ça se
passe au Japon, qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne. Donc sur différents sujets,
il y a des choses qui sont bonnes à
prendre et franchement si on n pas le
courage de le dire, qu'est-ce qu'on aura
le courage de faire ? si on n pas le
courage de dire qu'il y a des choses à
récupérer dans certains modèles. Enfin
bon,
pour l'anecdote, lever la main les
fonctionnaires et les commerçants.
Ouais. Et donc seul fit commerçant et
alors peut-être aussi que enfin je veux
pas la jouer, je suis très différente et
cetera. D'ailleurs, moi je crache pas du
tout sur les sur les études que j'ai
faites. Je me suis battu pour les faire.
J'ai travaillé pour avoir ces concours.
J'ai hérité de rien du tout. Je me suis
battu pour obtenir des grandes écoles.
Personne dans ma famille n'en avait fait
avant. Je vous ai dit, je viens de scène
Saint-Denis et c'était pas c'était pas
quelque chose qui m'était donné
d'avance. Donc je me suis battu pour
l'obtenir et je vais pas cracher dessus
aujourd'hui. On a beaucoup vu bah
notamment Macron cracher sur les nave,
vouloir supprimer les nave, vous vous
rappelez au lendemain des gilets jaunes
comme si c'était ça qui répondait à la
crise des gilets jaunes. À croire qu'il
avait rien compris au gilets jaunes.
30 pour lui.
Ouais. Il s'est dit il s'est dit ça fera
plaisir au gilets jaunes. Il avait rien
compris au gilets jaune d'ailleurs de
croire que c'est ce qui leur ferait
plaisir.
Donc d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on
parlait de la couleur. J'ai dit le
soleil au bout du tunnel mais il y a
plusieurs autres choses. Alors on m'a
dit le Tour de France, les gilets
jaunes, la coordination rurale,
le Crédit Lyonnais,
j'accepte les trois. Non, [rires] ça va,
il y a beaucoup d'autres choses qui sont
jaunes, mais je pouvais prendre soleil,
gilet jaune, coordination rurale, Tour
de France. C'est d'accord. Ça peut être
ça la signification du jeûne. Et donc
écoutez, j'espère que j'ai que je vais
répondre à la question non seulement par
ce que je viens de dire mais par la
suite de ce que je vais faire. Ce sera
ma meilleure réponse.
Question internet, ça ressemble à un
proverbe de grandi d'ailleurs, ça.
Euh question internet. Si vous deviez
citer une ville modèle qui a réussi
grâce à une gouvernance plus orientée
marché et à une responsabilisation
accrue des acteurs locaux tels que vous
le prenez ou vous la prenez. Laquelle
choisiss choisiriezvous
et pourquoi ?
Euh je dirais la Suisse un pour son
rapport au peuple une vraie démocratie.
Non mais une ville en Suisse alors
je vais dire la Suisse toute entière
parce que c'est vraiment le système
elvétique dans son ensemble. Une ville
qui fait confiance à son peuple. Pour
vous donner un exemple, on parlait tout
à l'heure de la taxe duman. Il y a eu un
référendum en Suisse juste avant Noël où
les jeunes socialiste voulaient
augmenter le taux des droits de
succession. Ils ont fait passer un
référendum, il y a eu 90 % de non. Les
Suisses ont refusé d'augmenter le taux
de droit de succession. Donc même des
gens qui n'allaient jamais le payer se
sont dit ce serait mauvais pour la
collectivité. Donc non. Et là, on voit à
quel point
le fait de faire confiance au peuple, le
fait de proposer par référendum ce genre
de sujet, ça crée une responsabilité, un
esprit civique, démocratique du peuple
qui apprend à décider pour lui-même. Et
c'est ce en quoi je crois beaucoup. Il y
avait une phrase de Miley qui disait "Je
ne suis pas là pour guider des moutons
mais pour réveiller des lions." Et je
pense exactement, c'est Charles Gav qui
dit ça aussi
et je pense je sais pas si Mila a copié
Charles Gav, ça m'étonnerait. Je pense
que Miley a copié Charles Gav. Ah bah
écoutez alors s'il a copié Charg
intériorité de ce proverbe, je crois que
c'était des annes euh des lions dirigés
par des Annes ou quelque chose comme ça.
Ça doit dater de
alors ça c'est 14, non c'est 1914.
Ah oui pardon.
C'est sur l'armée française. Je crois
pas qu'ils ont copié Charles Gavenon
dans l'armée française. Euh donc euh la
la Suisse parce que
182 ans. Charlin
il les [rires] fait pas.
La Suisse 1 pour le modèle démocratique
2 pour l'aspect empirique de la manière
qu'ils ont de gérer. Donc très
pragmatique sur leur politique publique
sans idéologie. C'est aussi ce que
j'essaie de faire dans mon programme
pour Paris.
Question d'ailleurs de Paris, parlons de
fausses promesses. Deux points. Votre
projet de couverture des voix surges,
s'il est bien en harmonie avec l'archit
l'architecture ospanienne a été chiffré
à 600 millions.
Tout à fait.
À quel moment ce chiffre est-il crédible
? Ils peuvent nous répondre les gens en
direct ou pas ?
Oui. Oui.
Alors, il peut nous dire à combien il le
chiffre lui et selon quels indicateurs.
Sylvin, tu es dans la merde, hein.
Non, mais j'aimerais bien savoir parce
qu'à chaque fois que les gens disent ça
a l'air de coûter pas cher, ça
m'intéresse de savoir pourquoi. Parce
que pour tout vous dire, celui qui l'a
chiffré, c'est un ingénieur en travaux
publics.
Le viaduc de Milo a coûté 350.
350 millions. Exactement. C'est la
meilleure réponse. C'est ce que c'est la
réponse que j'allais lui faire, mais
peut-être que il m'a déjà vu répondre
ça. Ou c'est un autre non ? Qui répond ?
Ça
c'est un autre.
Ouais, c'est un autre qui me défend.
Donc merci monsieur ou madame. Donc la
personne qui a chiffré ça, c'est un
ingénieur en travaux publics qui a
travaillé à la société du Grand Paris.
Il a construit des métros. Donc quand il
a proposé, quand il m'a dit voilà le
chiffrage, il m'a montré le tableur
Excel avec tous les coups, il m'a dit
c'est 60 millions d'euros. Mon premier
réflexe, ça a été de dire 60 millions
d'euros, ça m'a pas l'air beaucoup. Et
il me dit "D'accord, selon quels
indicateurs
Donc je me suis retrouvée de la même
manière que votre parly euh à dire bah
écoute, je sais pas, c'est parce que
j'entends très souvent des projets qui
coûtent plus cher. Un, ce n'est pas
parce que les autres font des gabis
invraisemblables qu'on en fera. C'est
même tout le contraire. Deux, c'est
parce que dans la plupart des projets,
ça demande de fermer des rues, de fermer
des axes de circulation, d'indemniser
des commerçants, ce qui là n'est pas le
cas. On parle donc parce que peut-être
que tout le monde n'a pas suivi de
rouvrir les voies surge à la circulation
automobile. On parle de la rive droite
de ce qui va du quai du Louvre à la
Bastie. C'est 2 km et donc de rouvrir
ces voies surge et de construire
au-dessus une promenade, j'essaie de
trouver la photo en même temps. De
construire aus au-dessus une magnifique
promenade. C'est ici. Je sais pas si la
caméra peut réussir à montrer. C'est
trop loin. Il va faire n'importe quoi
avec la caméra. Bon, j'essaie de montrer
un petit peu donc de construire
au-dessus des voies surges. Merci. Une
magnifique promenade pour les piétons,
les cyclistes, les personnes à mobilité
réduite sur des fauteuils roulants.
Ça va un bordel monstrueux dans
Paris quand
justement non. Voilà. Merci beaucoup de
me faire ma transition. C'est très
sympa. Quand vous devez construire cette
promenade au-dessus, vous n'avez à faire
les travaux que sur les quas pas sur les
quo. Donc vous ne devez rien fermer à la
circulation puisqueen dessous c'est déjà
fermé à la circulation. Il y a pas de
commerçant à indemniser. Il suffit de
poser des piliers tous les 10 m, de
couler une dalle au-dessus. Je sais pas
si vous avez fait déjà fait des travaux
chez vous. C'est le principe d'une
terrasse. Vous construisez une terrasse,
donc vous coulez une dalle sur des
piliers qui sont là sur 2 km. C'est 9 m
de portée. C'est pas le viaduc de Milo.
Le viaduc de Milo, ça a coûté 350
millions. Même si on actualisait en euro
d'aujourd'hui, ce serait 500 millions.
Ça ne peut pas coûter plus cher que le
viaduc de Milo de construire une
terrasse sur 9 m de portée. Donc ça a
été chiffré par un ingénieur en travaux
publics. Je n'aurais pas la prétention
de savoir chiffrer toute seule des
projets. Donc je m'entoure de gens qui
savent faire.
Je leur fais confiance.
Un ingénieur, ça veut dire quoi ? Ah non
mais ça
concepteur d'armes.
OK.
Euh je vais répondre à une question
parce qu'il y a une question qui nous
est directement posée. Avec ce qu'il se
passe actuellement dans le monde, il n'y
avait que Sarah Knafo dispo pour une
interview. Alors, il faut savoir que nos
interviews sont prévus très longtemps à
l'avance. Nous, ça doit peut-être faire
3 mois que que vous reveniez. Exact.
Et et je dis à cette personne, attends
de voir demain ce qu'on va te ramener
puis tu vas en reparler. OK. Parce que
on n'aime pas être dans l'actualité. On
est on aime être dans le temps long,
penser les choses en prenant en prenant
le temps. Mais de de temps en temps
comme on a quelques coups d'avance sur
la géopolitique, on peut se permettre
des fois de réagir à l'actualité.
Question internet. Je ne comprends pas
comment les loyers ont pu augmenter à
Saint-Paul s'ils sont encadrés. Que veut
dire encadrer ? Dans mon esprit, c'est
limiter le prix, établir un plafond. Par
quel mécanisme les loyers encadrés
augmentent ? Point d'interrogation.
Merci.
Très intéressante question. à laquelle
je répondais tout à l'heure en disant à
chaque fois qu'on essaie de brider
l'économie, l'économie se venge et donc
tous les contournements possibles ont
été utilisés. Notamment déclarer des
biens en résidence secondaire en bail
code civil pour pouvoir augmenter les
prix des loyers, décréter qu'il y a une
vue exceptionnelle, un service
exceptionnel dans l'appartement pour
pouvoir contourner l'encadrement des
loyers et donc faire continuer
d'augmenter les prix. Par ailleurs, la
pénurie sur le marché locatif. Donc, les
loyers ont continué d'augmenter par un
détournement de cet encadrement, ce qui
montre bien l'inefficacité. Et il y a
qu'à regarder ce que raconte la mairie
de Paris elle-même qui dit "Grâce à
l'encadrement des loyers, il y a eu une
modération de la hausse des loyers."
La question était en double tiroir. Et
si le vrai problème du logement parisien
n'était pas le niveau des loyers mais le
stock disponible ?
Donc l'encadrement des loyers a fait
baisser le stock disponible. Comme je
l'ai expliqué, depuis qu'on a encadré
les loyers en 2019, on a perdu 50000
logements sur le marché locatif.
Ensuite, si on parle du stock
disponible, moi je suis très attaché à
l'harmonie visuelle de Paris, à
l'identité architecturale de la ville.
Donc je dis pas qu'il faut bâtir partout
et construire comme des fous. Mon
objectif, c'est d'avoir un un plan local
d'urbanisme, un PLU qui soit totalement
revu par rapport à celui d'aujourd'hui.
Abroger le PLU bioclimatique, passer à
un PLU qui assure l'harmonie visuelle de
Paris. Et là, il y a une chose qu'on
peut construire, c'est ce qui s'appelle
des dents creuses. C'est-à-dire quand
vous avez deux bâtiments qui sont en en
ce format là. Donc, vous avez deux
bâtiments qui sont l'un à côté de
l'autre et au milieu, vous avez un
bâtiment qui a un étage ou deux étages
de moins. Là, vous pouvez surélever pour
que ça garde l'harmonie de Paris. Vous
avez comme ça une possibilité de créer
de l'offre, mais sinon sur le reste,
c'est déjà une ville qui est très dense
et on va pas mettre des tours partout.
Connaissez l'avenue Foche ?
Oui.
Question internet. Êtes-vous favorable à
l'ouverture d'une enquête sur l'étendue
des liens entre l'élite française et
l'affaire Epstein ?
Ah oui.
Ah je pense que la démocratie doit
toujours se nourrir de la transparence
et vice-versa.
Question.
Il s'agirait de savoir et d'ailleurs ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'on
a une mini potentielle à faire Epstein à
la ville de Paris. Il pass tout temps à
Paris. Non
donc il y a Non non attendez c'est pas
c'est pas ce que je veux dire. Vous avez
l'affaire Epstein à l'échelle mondiale
et là vous avez à l'échelle de la ville
de Paris. J'ai posé la question tout à
l'heure que se passe-t-il dans le
périscolaire parisien ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
a avec les enfants à Paris ? Regardons
ça aussi. Donc oui, totalement oui pour
savoir. On a le droit à la vérité. Je
crois que c'est un sujet majeur aussi ce
besoin de vérité.
Question internet. Quick des salles de
shoot. On veut une vraie position pour
interrogation. Faut-il encore toujours
cacher les gens qui souffrent de
toxicomanie dans cette société qui
semble de plus ne plus pardon qui semble
ne plus avoir les moyens de s'occuper
des laisser pour compte ?
Euh je suis opposé à l'ouverture de
salle de shoot parce que je considère
que le rôle des pouvoirs publics c'est
de sevrer et pas d'accompagner dans la
dépendance. On voit dans un rapport igas
que la présence de salles de shoot n'a
pas permis de réduire les addictions et
pour ces raisons, je pense que
construire de nouvelles salles de shoot
est une erreur. Je sais qu'il y a des
riverins et j'en entends qui ont pensé
quand il voyaient énormément de drogués
en bas de leur fenêtre qui ont pensé que
encadrer les choses ce serait mieux.
J'échange avec des riverrins, je nourris
aussi mes réflexions grâce à ça et je
m'aperçois qu'en réalité quand on a
construit des salles de shoot, ça a
plutôt emmené de nouveaux toxicoman que
réguler ce qu'il y avait déjà. Donc pour
ces raisons, j'y suis opposé. Donc
question beaucoup plus large euh et plus
géopolitique et énergétique. Bonjour
madame Knafo. Comment visagiez-vous la
reconquête de notre souveraineté
énergétique notamment à travers nos
centrales nucléaires ou à travers la
relance minière que représente par
exemple le projet minier Émilie, top 4
gisement mondial de lithium dans
l'allié. Merci. Dans mes souvenirs, on
avait beaucoup parlé de ces questions
lors du du premier entretien que j'avais
eu avec vous qui avait duré 4 heures.
Donc qui sera, je crois qu'il est un
record et qui sera plus long que celui
qu'on aura aujourd'hui parce que
malheureusement je vais bientôt devoir y
aller. Mais donc sur ces questions
si on vous autorise, enlevez-li les
menottes ou alors il ira voir il ira
voir il ira voir l'entretien qui a
liberté comme moi.
C'est tout à fait. Oui. Euh qu'est-ce
qu'elle voudrait qu'on dise de la France
dans 20 ans et quelles seraient ces tr à
cin priorités stratégiques pour
atteindre cette vision en tenant compte
de nécessaires investissement et
économie pour y parvenir sans bullshit
bien évidemment.
Question de Cyril
dans 20 ans.
Dans 20 ans,
bah déjà, j'aimerais qu'on dise que
c'est un pays heureux, un pays qui a
réussi à donner à ses habitants toutes
les conditions du bonheur. Alors,
évidemment, on peut pas faire le bonheur
des gens à leur place, mais il y a des
décisions publiques qui ont un impact
sur nos vies, sur notre moral, sur la
manière dont on est en sécurité ou pas
et donc prendre toutes les bonnes
décisions en mettant les Français au
cœur. J'aimerais qu'on dise que c'est
une grande démocratie, la plus belle
démocratie du monde. J'aimerais qu'on
dise que c'est un pays puissant, un pays
qui se respecte, un pays qui est
souverain. Et donc je dirais que c'est
très difficile de dire il y a une
priorité parce qu'en réalité c'est la
somme de diverses politiques publiques
qui peuvent permettre d'atteindre ce
résultat. Donc non seulement l'énergie
comme venait de le dire monsieur, la
sécurité, la fin du laxisme en matière
judiciaire, le niveau scolaire, le fait
de réussir à atteindre la pointe
technologique comme on l'a presque
toujours fait dans notre histoire, comme
on pourrait continuer à le faire sur
bien des secteurs où on est très bon, on
a encore,01
% de personnes qui sont à la pointe en
mathématiques. On a une excellente école
mathématique en France, l'école
polytechnique normale submat. On ne peut
réussir à à innover, à être à la pointe.
Et pour ça euh il faut qu'on soit
capable de soutenir nos champions. Il
faut qu'on arrête de leur mettre des
bâtons dans dans les roues, des des
boulets au pieds. C'est ce qu'on fait
presque tous les jours. Et euh par
conséquent, il faut à mon avis beaucoup
plus de de liberté pour favoriser nos
champions.
Alors, ça fait 2 heures qu'on est en
interview. Je vais vous lire un
commentaire
qui nous brise le cœur mais on va le
lire quand même.
Un commentaire de gens eux.
Bravo d'inviter une salle fachaud. Trois
points de suspension.
Plus ça va, plus on voit la tendance.
Trois points de suspension.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à ça ?
Bah déjà, c'est vous qui l'insulte.
Ouais. Et bah moi je me sens insulté
aussi d'ailleurs puisque Facho, je
considère que c'est absolument aberrant.
Je sais pas s'il me traite de fâcher. Je
sais pas combien de référendum Mussolini
avait fait pendant qu'il qu'il était à
la tête de l'Italie, mais je vous dirais
zéro. À l'inverse, vouloir gouverner
avec le peuple, je considère que c'est
au contraire la quintessence de la
démocratie. J'ai pas vu beaucoup de
personnes à l'extrême gauche et vu son
vocabulaire, je crois qu'il est plutôt
l'extrême gauche, j'ai pas vu beaucoup
de personnes à l'extrême gauche
respecter les libertés publiques ni
respecter la démocratie. Donc je prends
cette insulte pour ce qu'elle est une
insulte. C'est le contraire de ce que je
suis. Moi, je suis une jeune femme de
droite de tradition gauliste, formée par
Marie-France Garot. Euh j'ai été à
l'époque au républicain, j'ai été déçu.
Euh donc aujourd'hui, je représente, je
crois, la droite française telle qu'elle
n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être. Et
Marie-Fance qui nous donnait la
meilleure définition du mot forfaiture.
Euh et nous, on va y répondre euh aussi.
On invite qui on veut, on parle autant
de temps qu'on veut, avec qui on veut,
on est encore en France. On a invité
beaucoup la gauche, beaucoup l'extrême
gauche et on parle à qui on veut quand
on veut. Dernière question internet. Euh
vous avez récemment défendu la
vidéosurveillance augmentée par
intelligence artificielle pour Paris.
Comment réconciliez-vous cela avec les
principes de liberté individuelle que
vous prétendez défendre dans un contexte
où la technologie intelligence
artificielle risque d'éroder encore plus
les vies privées des citoyens ? Question
? Très bonne question. Donc, j'ai essayé
de construire un système de caméra de
surveillance qui soit le plus
respectueux des libertés publiques, plus
respectueux que celui qui existe
aujourd'hui. Aujourd'hui, vous avez des
caméras de surveillance à Paris, vous en
avez pas assez d'ailleurs, qui sont
regardés en permanence par des humains,
donc ils sont derrière les écrans. C'est
bien moins respectueux des libertés
publiques que le système que j'imagine,
à savoir un système où vous n'avez une
alerte que lorsque vous observez un
délit, un comportement suspect. À ce
moment-là, la caméra de surveillance est
activée auprès d'un opérateur qui doit
faire ce qu'on appelle une levée de
doute. Donc doit soit signaler qu'en
effet, il y a un problème et il compte
il appelle le commissariat le plus
proche, il y a une patrouille la plus
proche qui peut arriver très rapidement.
Ça n'est qu'à partir de ce moment-là que
la caméra enregistre. Donc vous pouvez
refuser qu'il y ait un enregistrement.
Vous pouvez par ailleurs demander qu'il
n'y ait pas de reconnaissance faciale,
mais qu'on reconnaisse des comportements
qui sont suspects sans reconnaissance
faciale. Il y a plusieurs gardes fou qui
peuvent être mis. Comme toujours pour la
technologie aujourd'hui, ce monsieur qui
nous écrit écrit sur YouTube, il est
certainement sur son téléphone,
sur Twitter. Donc en plus, il est sur un
réseau américain. Il y a plusieurs
manières de mettre des gardes fous sur
les technologies qu'on utilise. Moi,
c'est voici les gardes de fous que je
veux mettre à savoir un opérateur humain
n'y a accès que lorsqu'il y a un doute
et il y a un enregistrement, que
lorsqu'on a observé un délit et pas de
reconnaissance faciale. On peut mettre
ce garde fou.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Je voudrais trois livres à lire ou trois
livres que vous allez recommander à
notre que tu vas recommander à notre
communauté. Non mais pas vu qu'on s'est
fait traiter de facho et que on voit
maintenant notre ligne. Allez euh trois
bouquins importants pour notre
communauté à lire.
Alors je dirais le mal français de
Perfit. Le mal français en deux mots
parce que je dois en citer trois. Je
dirais le mal français. livre qui
explique à quel point plus une
collectivité grossit, une administration
ou une entreprise et plus cette
administration se tourne sur elle-même,
moins elle se met au service du public.
C'est un livre qui décrit parfaitement
la bureaucratie française qui explique
comment est-ce que à mesure que
l'administration a grossi, elle n'a plus
rendu le service qu'on était en droit
d'attendre d'elle mais elle s'est
recroquevillé sur elle-même dans un
système où le bureau A donne un ordre au
bureau B qui lui-même contrôle les
résultats du bureau C. Bref, des
processes dans tous les sens, une
administration invraisemblable. Le mal
français à l'infide, c'est écrit dans
les années 70, c'est hyper actuel. Ça
vaut absolument le coup euh d'être lu
parce que c'est ça ça dit où on en est
aujourd'hui. Euh 2e livre,
la première fois que j'étais venue, je
me souviens, j'avais suggéré Avril Brisé
de Ismaël Cadaré. Euh je pourrais le
redire. Je dis je donne toujours en
conseil des livres de Kundera, notamment
pour ceux qui veulent commencer la
littérature, pour ceux qui pensent
qu'ils ne se seuront pas qu' n'auront
pas le niveau Kundera. C'est vraiment
parfait. On entre tellement
naturellement, je dirais le livre du
rire et de l'oubli. Et dernier livre,
parce qu'il faut quand même un sujet
parisien, je dirais
euh Balzac, la comédie humaine. Donc là,
il y en a beaucoup à lire. On voit ce
que c'était, y compris au 19e siècle les
je la jeunesse française qui rêvait de
venir à Paris parce que pour eux Paris
c'était le symbole de tout, le symbole
de l'ambition pour ce qu'elle avait de
positif comme de négatif. le sab de la
gloire, de l'argent, de la puissance
industrielle, de la puissance
financière. Comment est-ce que une
génération entière de Français a rêvé de
Paris ? Et euh c'est presque un roman
policier. C'est c'est magnifique, ça se
lit facilement. Parfois, on peut avoir
une appréhension en se disant "Je vais
rentrer dans Balzac, c'est long et
cetera." C'est idéal aussi pour
commencer à lire. Donc Balzac, la
comédie humaine.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
qui va rester impérissable sur les
réseaux avant qu'on se fasse squeezé par
le DSA de l'Europe qui va interdire
toute voix de contestataire.
H
je vous laisse réfléchirend d'apprendre
à vivre dans un monde avec Lia, euh
d'être fort en math quand on quand on
est encore à l'école, d'être fort en
math, d'apprendre l'histoire. Je pense
que ce sont les deux choses
insubersibles qu'on qu'on gardera.
C'est-à-dire qu'on aura besoin d'un fort
esprit critique permis grâce à une
culture générale solide. Donc la
connaissance de l'histoire va nous y
aider et on aura besoin d'un esprit
logique et pour pouvoir prompter et pour
pouvoir juger les résultats qui vont
nous être donnés. Donc les maths, je
pense que ce sont les deux seules choses
qui vont rester universelles,
universellement nécessaires pour être
complet et que peut-être que dans
quelques années toutes les verticales
d'ultra spécialisation seront devenues
obsolètes du fait de l'intelligence
artificielle. Donc de rester à la page
parce que l'être humain aura toujours
une valeur ajoutée énorme et à eux de la
cultiver. Et donc nous comme on s'est
fait traiter de faud avec toi, on te
propose tout de suite une prochaine
interview n'importe que quel que soit le
j'adore. Merci Jeanud. Merci pour cette
opportunité. Et
et à chaque fois qu'on se fera traiter
de fachot, on invitera quelqu'un qui
sera considéré euh comme ça juste parce
que on est français et qu'on aime bien
dire merde.
Vive la liberté, vive la France.
Sarcino. Merci.
Merci.
[musique]